the problem is that we do not get 50
years to try and try again and observe
that we were wrong and come up with a
different Theory and realize that the
entire thing is going to be like way
more difficult and realized at the start
because the first time you fail at
aligning something much smarter than you
are you die
the following is a conversation with
Eliezer yatkowski a legendary researcher
writer and philosopher on the topic of
artificial intelligence especially super
intelligent AGI and its threat to human
civilization
this is the Lex Friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's Eliezer idkowski
what do you think about gpt4 how
intelligent is it
it is a bit smarter than I thought this
technology was going to scale to
and I'm a bit worried about what the
next one will be like like this
particular one I think
I hope there's nobody inside there
because you know it would be sucked to
be stuck inside there
um but we don't even know the
architecture at this point because open
AI is very properly not telling us
and
yeah like giant inscrutable matrices of
floating Point numbers I don't know
what's going on in there nobody's goes
knows what's going on in there all we
have to go by are the external metrics
and on the external metrics if you
ask it to write a self-aware fortune
green text it will start writing a green
text about how it has realized that it's
an AI writing a green text and like oh
well so
that's probably
not quite what's going on in there in
reality
um but we're kind of like blowing past
all these science fiction guard rails
like we are past the point where in
science fiction people would be like
whoa wait stop that thing's live what
are you doing to it
and it's probably not
nobody actually knows we don't have any
other guard rails we don't have any
other tests we don't have any lines to
draw on the sand and say like well when
we get this far we will start to worry
about
what's inside there
so if it were up to me I would be like
okay like this far no further time for
the summer of AI where we have planted
our seeds and now we like wait and reap
the rewards of the technology we've
already developed and don't do any
larger training runs than that which to
be clear I realize requires more than
one company agreeing to not do that
and take a rigorous approach for the
whole AI Community to uh investigate
whether there's somebody inside there
that would take decades
like having any idea of what's going on
in there people have been trying for a
while it's a poetic statement about if
there's somebody in there but as I feel
like it's also a technical statement or
I hope it is one day
which is a technical statement with that
Alan Turing tried to come up with with
the touring test
do you think it's possible to
definitively
or approximately figure out if there is
somebody in there if there's something
like a mind inside this large language
model
I mean there's a whole bunch of
different sub questions here there's the
question of
like
is there Consciousness is there qualia
is this a object of moral concern is the
same oral patient
um like should we be worried about how
we're treating it
and then there's questions like how
smart is it exactly can it do X can it
do y and we can check how it can do X
and how it can do y
um unfortunately we've gone and exposed
this model to a vast Corpus of text of
people discussing Consciousness on the
internet which means that when it talks
about being self-aware we don't know to
what extents it is repeating back what
it has previously been trained on for
discussing self-awareness
or if there's anything going on in there
such that it would start to say similar
things spontaneously
um
among the things that one could do if
one were at all serious
um about trying to figure this out is
train gpt3 to detect conversations about
Consciousness exclude them all from the
training data sets and then retrain
something around the rough size of gpt4
and no larger
with all of the discussion of
Consciousness and self-awareness and so
on missing although you know hard hard
bar to pass you know like you humans are
self-aware we're like self-aware all the
time we like talk about what we do all
the time like what we're thinking at the
moment all the time
but nonetheless like get rid of the
explicit discussion of Consciousness I
think therefore I am and all that and
then try to interrogate that model
and see what it says and it still would
not be definitive
but nonetheless uh
I don't know I feel like when you run
over this science fiction guard rails
like maybe this thing but what about gbt
maybe maybe not this thing but like what
about gpt5 you know this this would be a
good place to to pause
on the topic of cautiousness you know
there's so many components
to even just removing Consciousness from
the data set
emotion the display of Consciousness the
display of emotion feels like deeply
integrated with the experience of
consciousness
so the hard problem seems to be very
well integrated with the actual surface
level illusion of Consciousness so
displaying emotion
I mean do you think there's a case to be
made that we humans when we're babies
are just like gbt that we're training on
human data on how to display emotion
versus feel emotion how to show others
communicate others
that I'm suffering that I'm excited that
I'm worried
that I'm lonely and I missed you and I'm
excited to see you all of that is
communicated there's a communication
skill versus the actual feeling that I
experience so
we need that training data as humans too
that we may not be born with that how to
communicate the internal State and
that's in some sense if we remove that
from GPT Force data set it might still
be conscious but not be able to
communicate it
so I think you're going to have some
difficulty removing all mention of
emotions from gpt's data set I would be
relatively surprised to find that it has
developed exact analogs of human
emotions and there I think that humans
have well like have like
emotions even if you don't tell them
about those emotions when they're kids
it's not quite exactly what
various blanks blank slightests try to
do with the new Soviet man and all that
but you know if you try to raise people
perfectly altruistic they still come out
selfish
you try to raise people's sexless they
still develop sexual attraction
um
you know we have some notion in humans
not in AIS of like where the brain
structures are that implement this stuff
and it is really remarkable thing I say
in passing that despite having complete
read access to every floating Point
number in
the GPT series we still know vastly more
about the the architecture of human
thinking then we know about what goes on
inside GPT despite having like vastly
better ability to read GPT
do you think it's possible do you think
that's just a matter of time do you
think it's possible to investigate and
study the way neuroscientists study the
brain
which is look into the darkness The
Mystery of the human brain by just
desperately trying to figure out
something and to form models and then
over a long period of time actually
start to figure out what regions of the
brain do certain things with different
kinds of neurons when they fire what
that means how plastic the brain is all
that kind of stuff you slowly start to
figure out different properties of the
system do you think we can do the same
thing with language models uh sure I
think that if you know like half of
today's physicists stop wasting their
lives on string theory or whatever
and go off and study
um what goes on inside Transformer
networks
um then in
you know like 30 40 years uh we'd
probably have a pretty good idea
do you think these large language models
can reason
they can play chess how are they doing
that without reasoning
so
you're somebody that spearheaded the
movement of rationality so reason is
important to you
is so is that as a powerful important
word or is it like how difficult is the
threshold of being able to reason to you
and how impressive is it I mean
in my writings on rationality I have not
gone making a big deal out of something
called reason I have made more of a big
deal out of something called probability
Theory
and that's like well your reasoning but
you're not doing it quite right
and you should reason this way instead
and interestingly like people have
started to get preliminary results
showing that
reinforcement learning by human feedback
has made the GPT series worse in some
ways
in particular like it used to be well
calibrated if you trained it to put
probabilities on things it would say 80
probability and we write eight times out
of ten and if you apply reinforcement
learning from Human feedback the the
like nice graph of like like 70 7 out of
ten
sort of like flattens out into the graph
that humans use where there's like some
very improbable stuff and
likely probable maybe which all means
like around 40 percent and then certain
yeah so like it's like it used to be
able to use probabilities but if you
apply but if you'd like try to teach it
to talk in a way that satisfies humans
it it gets worse at probability in the
same way that humans are and that's uh
that's a bug not a feature I would call
it a bug
although such a fascinating bug
um but but but yeah so so like reasoning
like it's doing pretty well on various
tests that people used to say would
require reasoning but
um you know rationality is about
when you say eighty percent doesn't
happen eight times out of ten
so what are the limits to you of these
Transformer Networks
of of neural networks which if if
reasoning is not impressive to you or it
is impressive but there's other levels
to achieve I mean it's just not how I
carve up reality
what's uh if reality is a cake
what are the different layers of the
cake or the slices how do you cover it
but you can use a different food if you
like
it's I don't think it's as smart as a
human yet
um I do like back in the day I went
around saying like I do not think that
just stacking more layers of
Transformers is going to get you all the
way to AGI and I think that's gpt4 is
passed or I thought this Paradigm was
going to take us
and I you know you want to notice when
that happens you want to say like whoops
well I guess I was incorrect about what
happens if you keep on stacking more
Transformer layers and that means I
don't necessarily know what gpt5 is
going to be able to do that's a powerful
statement so you're saying like your
intuition initially is now appears to be
wrong yeah
it's good to see that you can admit in
some of your predictions to be wrong
do you think that's important to do see
because you make several very throughout
your life you've made many strong
predictions and statements about reality
and you evolve with that so maybe
that'll come up today about our
discussion so you're okay being wrong
I'd rather not
be wrong next time it's a bit ambitious
to go through your entire life never
having been wrong
um
one can aspire to be well calibrated
like not so much think in terms of like
was I right was I wrong but like when I
said 90 that it happened nine times out
of ten
yeah like oops is the sound we make is
the sound we emit when we improve
beautifully said and somewhere in there
it we can connect the name of your blog
less wrong
I suppose that's the objective function
the name less wrong was I believe uh
suggested by Nick Bostrom and it's after
someone's epigraph actually forget who's
who said like we never become right we
just become less wrong
um what's the something something to
easy to confess just error and error and
air again but less and less and less
yeah that's that's a good thing to
strive for uh so
what has surprised you about gpt4 that
you found beautiful as a scholar of
intelligence of human intelligence of
artificial intelligence of the human
mind
I mean
the beauty does interact with the
screaming horror
um is the beauty in the horror but uh
but like Beautiful Moments well somebody
asked Bing Sydney to describe herself
and felt the resulting description into
one of the stable diffusion things I
think
and you know she you know it's she's
pretty and this is something that should
have been like an amazing moment like
the AI describes herself you get to see
what the AI thinks the AI looks like
although you know the the thing that's
doing the drawing is not the same thing
that's outputting the text
um
and
it's it doesn't happen the way that it
would happen and that it happened in the
old school science fiction when you ask
an AI to make a picture of what it looks
like
um not just because we're two different
AI systems being stacked that don't
actually interact it's not the same
person but also because
the AI was trained by imitation in a way
that makes it very difficult to guess
how much of that it really understood
and probably not actually a whole bunch
um although although gpt4 is like
multimodal and can like draw vector
drawings of things that make sense and
like does appear to have some kind of
spatial visualization going on in there
but like the the pretty picture of the
like girl with the
with the uh steampunk goggles on her
head if I'm remembering correctly what
she looked like like it didn't see that
in full detail
it just like made a description of it
and stable diffusion output it and
there's the concern about
how much the discourse is going to go
completely insane once the AIS all look
like that and like are actually look
like people talking
um and
yeah there's like another moment where
somebody is asking Bing about
um like well I like fed my kid green
potatoes and they have the following
symptoms and being as like that solanine
poisoning and like call an ambulance and
the person's like I can't afford an
ambulance I guess if like this is time
for like my kid to go that's God's Will
and the main Bing thread says gives the
like message of like I cannot talk about
this anymore
and the suggested replies to it say
please don't give up on your child
solanine poisoning can be treated if
caught early
and you know if that happened in fiction
that would be like the AI cares the AI
is bypassing the block on it to try to
help this person
and is it real probably not but nobody
knows what's going on in there
it's part of a process where these
things are not happening in a way where
we
somebody figured out how to make an AI
care and we know that it cares and we
can acknowledge it's caring now it's
being trained by this imitation process
followed by reinforcement learning on
human in human feedback and we're like
trying to point it in this direction and
it's like pointed partially in this
direction and nobody has any idea what's
going on inside it and if there was a
tiny fragment of real caring in there we
would not know it's not even clear what
it means exactly and uh things are clear
cut in science fiction we'll talk about
the the horror and the terror and the
where the trajectories this can take but
this seems like a very special moment
just a moment where we get to interact
with the system that might have care and
kindness and emotion it may be something
like consciousness
and we don't know if it does and we're
trying to figure that out and we're
wondering about what is what it means to
care we're trying we're trying to figure
out almost different aspects of what it
means to be human about The Human
Condition by looking at this AI that has
some of the properties of that it's
almost like this the subtle fragile
moment in the history of the human
species we're trying to almost put a
mirror to ourselves here except that's
probably not yet it probably isn't
happening right now
we are we are boiling the Frog we are
seeing increasing signs bit by bit
because like not but not like
spontaneous signs because people are
trying to train the systems to do that
using imitative learning and the
imitative learning is like spilling over
and having side effects and and the most
photogenic examples are being posted to
Twitter
um rather than being examined in any
systematic way so when you when you when
you have some when you are boiling a
frog like that or you're going to get
like like first is going to come the the
Blake lemoines like first you're going
to like have and have like a thousand
people looking at this and one out and
the one person out of a thousand who is
most credulous about the signs is going
to be like that thing is sentient well
90 999 out of a thousand people think
almost surely correctly though we don't
actually know that he's mistaken
and so the like first people to say like
sentience look like idiots and Humanity
learns the lesson that when something
claims to be sentient
and claims to care
it's fake because it is fake because we
have been trained them training them
using imitative learning rather than and
this is not spontaneous
um and they keep getting smarter
do you think we would oscillate between
that kind of cynicism
that AI systems can't possibly be
sentient they can't possibly feel
emotion they can't possibly this kind of
um yeah cynicism about AI systems and
then
oscillate to a state where
uh we empathize with the AI systems we
give them a chance we see that they
might need to have rights and respect
and
um similar role in society as humans
you're going to have a whole group of
people who can just like never be
persuaded of that because to them like
being wise being cynical being skeptical
is to be like oh well machines can never
do that you're just credulous it's just
imitating it's just fooling you and like
they would say that right up until the
end of the world and possibly even be
right because you know they are being
trained on an imitative paradigm
and you don't necessarily need any of
these actual qualities in order to kill
everyone so have you observed yourself
working through skepticism
cynicism and optimism about the power of
neural networks what is that trajectory
been like for you it looks like neural
networks before 2006 forming part of an
indistinguishable to me
other people might have had better
Distinction on it indistinguishable blob
of different AI methodologies all of
which are promising to achieve
intelligence without us having to know
how intelligence works
you have the people who said that if you
just like manually program lots and lots
of knowledge into the system line by
line at some point all the knowledge
will start interacting it will know
enough and it will wake up
um you've got people saying that if you
just use evolutionary computation if you
try to like mutate lots and lots of
organisms that are competing together
that's that's the same way that human
intelligence was produced in nature so
we'll do this and it will wake up
without having the idea of how AI works
and you've got people saying well we
will study neuroscience and we will like
learn the outer we'll learn the
algorithms off the neurons and we will
like imitate them without understanding
those algorithms which was a part I was
pretty skeptical it's like hard to
reproduce re-engineer these things
without understanding what they do
um and like and and so we will get AI
without understanding how it works and
there were people saying like well we
will have giant neural networks that we
will Train by gradient descent and when
they are as large as the human brain
they will wake up we will have
intelligence without understanding how
intelligence works and from my
perspective this is all like an
indistinguishable lab of people who are
trying to not get to grips with the
difficult problems understanding how
intelligence actually works
that said
I was never skeptical that evolutionary
computation
would not work in the limit like you
throw enough computing power at it it
obviously works
that is where humans come from
um and it turned out that you can throw
less computing power than that at
gradient descent
if you are doing some other things
correctly
and you will get intelligence without
having any idea of how it works and what
is going on inside
um it wasn't ruled out by my model that
this could happen I wasn't expecting it
to happen I wouldn't have been able to
call neural networks rather than any of
the other paradigms for getting like
massive amount like intelligence without
understanding it
and I wouldn't have said that this was a
particularly smart thing for a species
to do which is an opinion that has
changed less than my opinion about
whether you or not you can actually do
it
do you think AGI could be achieved with
a neural network as we understand them
today yes
just flatly last yes the question is
whether the current architecture of
stacking more Transformer layers which
for all we know gpt4 is no longer doing
because they're not telling us the
architecture which is a correct decision
oh correct decision I had a conversation
with Sam Altman will return to this
topic a few times
he turned the question to me
of how open should open AI be about gpt4
would you open source the code he asked
me
because I provided as criticism saying
that while I do appreciate transparency
open AI could be more open
and he says we struggle with this
question what would you do change their
name to closed AI and like
sell gpt4 to business backend
applications that don't expose it to
Consumers and Venture capitalists and
create a ton of hype and like pour a
bunch of new funding into the area but
too late now but don't you think others
would do it
eventually you shouldn't do it first
like if if you already have giant
nuclear stockpiles don't build more
if some other country starts building a
larger nuclear stockpile than sure build
then you know
even then maybe just have enough nukes
you know there's a these things are not
quite like nuclear weapons they spit out
gold until they get large enough and
then ignite the atmosphere and kill
everybody
um
and there is something to be said for
not destroying the world with your own
hands even if you can't stop somebody
else from doing it
but but open sourcing it now that that's
just sheer catastrophe oh the whole
notion of open sourcing this was always
the wrong approach the wrong ideal there
are there are places in the world where
open source is a noble ideal and
building stuff you don't understand that
is difficult to control that where if
you could align it it would take time
you'd have to spend a bunch of time
doing it that is that is not a place for
open source because then you just have
like powerful things that just like go
straight out the gate without anybody
having had the time to have them not
kill everyone
so can we still man the case for
some level of transparency and openness
maybe open sourcing
so the case could be that because gpt4
is not close to AGI if that's the case
that this does allow open sourcing
you're being open about the architecture
being transparent about maybe research
and investigation of how the thing works
of all the different aspects of it of
its behavior of its structure of of its
training processes of the data was
trained on everything like that that
allows us to gain a lot of insight about
alignment about the alignment problem to
do really good AI Safety Research while
the system is not too powerful can you
make that case that it could be a
resource I do not believe in the
practice of Steel Manning there's
something to be said for trying to pass
the ideological Turing test where you
describe your opponent's position uh the
disagree disagreeing person's position
well enough that somebody cannot tell
the difference between your description
and their description
but
steel Manning no like okay well this is
where you and I disagree here that's
interesting why don't you believe in
steel Manning I do not want okay so for
one thing if somebody's trying to
understand me I do not want them steel
Manning my position I want them to
describe to to like try to describe my
position the way I would describe it not
what they think is an improvement
well I I think that is what
the steel Manning is is the most
charitable interpretation
I I don't want to be interpreted
charitably I want them to understand
what I'm actually saying if they go off
into the land of charitable
interpretations they're like often their
land of like
the thing the stuff they're imagining
and not trying to understand my own
Viewpoint anymore well I'll put it
differently then just to push on this
point I would say it is restating what I
think you understand
under the empathetic assumption that
Eliezer is brilliant
and have honestly and rigorously thought
about the point he has made right so if
there's two possible interpretations of
what I'm saying and one interpretation
is really stupid and whack and doesn't
sound like me and doesn't fit with the
rest of what I've been saying and one
interpretation you know sounds like some
like something a reasonable person who
believes the rest of what I believe
would also say go with the second
interpretation that's steel Manning
that's that's a good guess
if on the other hand you like there's
like
something that sounds completely whack
and something that sounds like a little
less completely whack but you don't see
why I would believe in it doesn't fit
with the other stuff I say but you know
it sounds like less whack and you can
like sort of see you could like maybe
argue it then you probably have not
understood it see okay I'm gonna this is
fun because I'm gonna Linger on this you
know you wrote a brilliant blog post AJ
I ruined a list of lethalities right and
it was a bunch of different points and I
would say that some of the points are
bigger and more powerful than others if
you were to sort them you probably could
you personally and to me steel Manning
means like going through the different
arguments and finding the ones that are
really the most like
powerful if people like tlgr
like what should you be most concerned
about and bringing that up in a strong
uh compelling eloquent way these are the
points that elieza would make to to make
the case in this case that hey it's
gonna kill all of us but that that
that's what steel Manning is presenting
it in a really nice way the summary of
my best understanding of your
perspective that because to me there's a
sea of possible presentations of your
perspective and steel Manning is doing
your best to do the best one in that sea
of different perspectives do you believe
it
don't believe in what like these things
that you would be presenting as like the
strongest version of my perspective do
you believe what you would be presenting
do you think it's true
I I'm a big proponent of empathy when I
see the perspective of a person
there is a part of me that believes it
if I understand it and you have
especially in political discourse in
geopolitics I've been hearing a lot of
different perspectives on the world
and I hold my own opinions but I also
speak to a lot of people that have a
very different life experience and a
very different set of beliefs and I
think there has to be epistemic humility
in
in stating what is true so when I
empathize with another person's
perspective there is a sense in which I
believe it is true
I I think probabilistically I would say
in the way you think do you bet money on
it
and do you bet money on their beliefs
when you believe them
are we allowed to do probability
sure you can State a probability that
yes there's there's a loose there's a
probability there's a there's a
probability and I I think empathy is
allocating a non-zero probability to
believe
in some sense for time
if you've got someone on your show who
believes in the abrahamic deity
classical style somebody on the show
who's a young Earth creationist do you
say I put a probability on it then
that's my empathy
when you reduce beliefs into
probabilities it starts to get you know
we can even just go to Flat Earth is the
earth flat
because I think it's a little more
difficult nowadays to find people who
believe that unironically but
fortunately
I think well it's hard to know an ironic
yeah
from ironic but I think there's quite a
lot of people that believe that yeah
it's
there's a space of argument where you're
operating in rationally in the space of
ideas but then there's also
a kind of discourse where you're
operating in the space of
subjective experiences and life
experiences like
I think what it means to be human is
more than just
searching for truth
it's just operating of what is true and
what is not true I think there has to be
deep humility that we humans are very
limited in our ability to understand
what is true
so what probabilities do you assign to
the young Earth's creationists beliefs
then
I think I have to give non-zero out of
your humility yeah but like
three
I think I would uh it would be
irresponsible for me to give a number
because the The Listener the way the
human mind works
we're not good at hearing the
probabilities
right you hear three what is what is
three exactly right they're going to
hear they're going to like well there's
only three probabilities I feel like
zero fifty percent and a hundred percent
in the human mind or something like this
right well zero forty percent and 100 is
a bit closer to it based on what happens
to chat GPT after RL H effort to speak
humanies this is brilliant uh yeah this
is that's really interesting I didn't I
didn't know those negative side effects
of rohf that's fascinating but uh just
to uh return to the
open AI close there also like quick
disclaimer I'm doing all this for memory
I'm not pulling out my phone to look it
up it is entirely possible that the
things I'm saying are wrong so thank you
for that disclaimer so uh uh and thank
you for
what being willing to be wrong
that's beautiful to hear
I think being willing to be wrong is a
sign of a person who's done a lot of
thinking about this world and
has been humbled by the mystery and the
complexity of this world and I think
a lot of us are resistant to admitting
we're wrong because it hurts it hurts
personally
it hurts especially when you're a public
human it hurts publicly because people
uh
people point out every time you're wrong
like look you change your mind you're
hypocrite you're uh an idiot whatever
whatever they want to say oh I block
those people and then I never hear from
them again on Twitter
the point is uh the point is to not let
that pressure public pressure affect
your mind and be willing to be in the
privacy of your mind
to contemplate
the possibility that you're wrong and
the possibility that you're wrong about
the most fundamental things you believe
like people who believe in a particular
God or people who believe that their
nation is the greatest nation on Earth
but all those kinds of beliefs that are
core to who you are when you come up to
raise that point to yourself in the
privacy of your mind and say maybe I'm
wrong about this that's a really
powerful thing to do especially when
you're somebody who's thinking about uh
topics that can uh about systems that
can destroy human civilization or maybe
help with flourish so thank you thank
you for being willing to be wrong
about open AI
so you really
I just would love to linger on this you
really think it's wrong to open source
it I think that burns the time remaining
until everybody dies I think we are not
on track
to learn remotely near fast enough
even if it were open sourced
um yeah that's
I it's easier to think that you might be
wrong about something when being wrong
about something is the
is the only way that there's hope
and
it doesn't seem very likely to me that
the particular thing I'm wrong about is
that this is a great time to open source
GPT for
if Humanity was trying to survive at
this point in the straightforward way it
would be like shutting down the big GPU
clusters
no more giant runs
it's questionable whether we should even
be throwing gpt4 around although that is
a matter of conservatism rather than a
matter of my predicting that catastrophe
will follow from gpd4 that is something
else I put like a pretty low probability
but also like when I when I say like I
put a low probability on it I can feel
myself reaching into the part of myself
that thought that gbt4 was not possible
in the first place so I do not trust
that part as much as I used to
like the trick is not just to say I'm
wrong but like okay well I was I was
wrong about that like can I get out
ahead of that curve and like predict the
next thing I'm going to be wrong about
so the set of assumptions or the actual
reasoning system that you were
leveraging in making that initial
statement prediction
uh how can you adjust that to make
better predictions about GPT four five
six you don't want to keep on being
wrong in a predictable Direction yeah
that like being wrong anybody has to do
that walking through the world there's
like no way you don't say 90 and
sometimes be wrong in fact adap at least
one time out of ten if you're well
calibrated when you say 90 percent
the the undignified thing is not being
wrong it's being predictably wrong it's
being wrong in the same direction over
and over again
so having been wrong about how far
neural networks would go and having been
wrong specifically about whether gpt4
would be as impressive as it is when I
like when I say like well I don't
actually think GPT 4 causes a
catastrophe I do feel myself relying on
that part of me that was previously
wrong and that does not mean that the
answer is now in the opposite direction
reverse stupidity is not intelligence
but it does mean that I that I say it
with a
with the worry note in my voice it's
like still my guess but like you know
it's a place where I was wrong maybe you
should be asking guern branwin guern
branwin has been like writer about this
than I have maybe ask him if you think
if if he thinks it's dangerous rather
than asking me
I think there's a lot of mystery about
what intelligence is
what AGI looks like
so I think all of us are rapidly
adjusting our model but the point is to
be rapidly adjusting the model versus
having a model that was right in the
first place I do not feel that seeing
Bing has changed my model of what
intelligence is it has changed my
understanding of what kind of work can
be performed by which kind of processes
and by which means does not change my
understanding of the work there's a
difference between thinking that the
right flyer can't fly and then like it
does fly and you're like oh well I guess
you can do that with wings with
fixed-wing aircraft and being like Oh
it's flying this changes my picture of
what the very substance of flight is
that's like a stranger update to make
and Bing has not yet updated me in that
way
um yeah that uh the laws of physics
are actually wrong that kind of update
no no like just like oh like I Define
intelligence this way but I now see that
was a stupid definition I don't feel
like the way that things have played out
over the last 20 years has caused me to
feel that way
can we try to
um on the way to talking about AGI ruin
a list of lethalities that blog and
other ideas around it can we try to
Define AGI that would be mentioning how
do you like to think about what
artificial general intelligence is or
super intelligence is that is there a
line is it a gray area
is there a good definition for you well
if you look at humans humans have
significantly more generally applicable
intelligence compared to their closest
relatives the chimpanzees well closest
living relatives rather
and a b builds highs a beaver builds
dams a human will look at a B Hive and a
beavers Dam and be like oh like can I
build a hive without a honeycomb
structure I don't like hexagonal tiles
and we will do this even though at no
point during our
ancestry was any human optimized to
build hexagonal dams or to take a more
clear-cut case we can go to the Moon
there's a sense in which we were on a
sufficiently deep level optimized to do
things like going to the Moon because if
you generalize sufficiently far and
sufficiently deeply chipping Flint hand
axes
and outwitting your fellow humans is you
know
basically the same problem is going to
the moon and you optimize hard enough
for chipping Flint hand axes and
throwing Spears and above all outwitting
your fellow humans in tribal politics
uh you know the the the the the skills
you entrain that way if they run deep
enough
let you go to the Moon
even though none of your ancestors like
tried repeatedly to fly to the moon and
like got further each time and the ones
who got further each time had more kids
no it's not an ancestral problem it's
just that the ancestral problems
generalize far enough
so this is Humanity's significantly more
generally applicable intelligence
is there
a way to measure
general intelligence
I mean I could ask that question a
million ways but basically
is will you know it when you see it
it being in an AGI system
if you boil a frog gradually enough if
you zoom in far enough it's always hard
to tell around the edges gpt4 people are
saying right now like this looks to us
like a spark of general intelligence it
is like able to do all these things it
was not explicitly optimized for yeah
other people are being like no it's too
early it's like like 50 years off and
you know if they say that they're kind
of whack because how could they possibly
know that even if it were true
um
but uh but you know not to straw man
some of people may say like that's not
general intelligence and not furthermore
append it's 50 years off
um
or they may be like it's only a very
tiny amount
and you know the thing I would worry
about is that if this is how things are
scaling then jumping out ahead and
trying not to be wrong in the same way
that I've been wrong before maybe GPT 5
is more unambiguously a general
intelligence and maybe that is getting
to a point where it is like even harder
to turn back not that it would be easy
to turn back now but you know maybe if
you let if you like start integrating
gpt5 into the economy it is even harder
to turn back past there
isn't it possible that there's a you
know with a frog metaphor you can kiss
the Frog and it turns into a prince as
you're boiling it could there be a phase
shift in the Frog where unambiguously as
you're saying I was expecting more of
that I I was I am like the the fact that
gpt4 is like kind of on the threshold in
either here nor there like that itself
is like
not the sort of thing that not quite how
I expected it to play out
I was expecting there to be more of an
issue uh more of a sense of like like
different discoveries like the discovery
of Transformers
where you would stack them up and there
would be like a final Discovery and then
you would like get something that was
like more clearly general intelligence
so the the way that you are like taking
what is probably basically the same
architecture is in gpt3 and throwing 20
times as much computed
probably and getting out gbt4 and then
it's like maybe just barely a general
intelligence or like a narrow general
intelligence or you know something we
don't really have the words for
um
yeah that is uh that's not quite how I
expected it to play out but this middle
what appears to be this Middle Ground
could nevertheless be actually a big
leap from gpt3
it's definitely a big leap from gpt3 and
then maybe we're another one big leap
away from something that's that's a
phase shift and also something that uh
Sam Altman said
and you've written about this it's just
fascinating which is the thing that
happened with gpt4 that I guess they
don't describe in papers is that they
have like hundreds if not thousands of
little hacks
that improve the system you've written
about railue versus sigmoid for example
a function inside neural networks it's
like this silly little function
difference
that makes a big difference I mean we do
actually understand why the relatives
make a big difference compared to
sigminds but yes they're probably using
like
g4789 Ellis or you know whatever the
acronyms are up to now rather than relus
um yeah that's that's just part yeah
that's part of the modern Paradigm of
alchemy you take your time heap of
linear algebra and you stir it and it
works a little bit better and you store
it this way and it works a little bit
worse and you like throw out that change
and nothing
but there's some simple
breakthroughs
that are definitive
jumps in performance like regulars over
sigmoids and uh in terms of robustness
in terms of you know in all kinds of
measures and like those Stack Up
and they can it's possible that some of
them
could be a non-linear jump in
performance right Transformers are the
main thing like that and various people
are now saying like well if you throw
enough compute rnns can do it if you
throw enough compute dense networks can
do it and
not quite a gpt4 scale
um it is possible that like all these
little tweaks are things that like save
them a factor of three total on
computing power and you could get the
same performance by throwing three times
as much compute without all the little
tweaks
but the part where it's like running on
so there's a question of like is there
anything in gpt4 that is like kind of
qualitative shift that Transformers were
yeah over
um rnns
and if they have anything like that they
should not say it
if Sam Alton was dropping hints about
that he shouldn't have dropped hints
uh so you you have a that's an
interesting question so with a bit of
Lesson by Rich Sutton maybe a lot of it
is just
a lot of the hacks are just temporary
jumps and performance that would be
achieved anyway
with the nearly exponential growth of
compute
or performance of compute
compute being broadly defined do you
still think that Moore's Law continues
Moore's Law broadly defined the
performance is not a specialist in the
circuitry I certainly like pray that
Moore's Law runs as slowly as possible
and if it broke down completely tomorrow
I would dance through the streets
singing Hallelujah as soon as the news
were announced
only not literally because you know
you're singing voice oh okay
I thought you meant you don't have an
Angelic Voice singing voice
well let me ask you what can you
summarize the main points in the blog
post AGI ruin a list of lethalities
things then jump to your mind because
um it's a set of thoughts you have about
reasons why AI is likely to kill all of
us
so I I guess I could but I would offer
to instead say like
drop that empathy with me I bet you
don't believe that
why don't you tell me about how why you
believe that AGI is not going to kill
everyone
and then I can like try to describe how
my theoretical perspective differs from
that
so well that means I have to uh the word
you don't like the Steel Man the
perspective that yeah is not going to
kill us I think that's a matter of
probabilities maybe I was mistaken what
what do you believe
just just like forget like the the
debate and and the like dualism and just
like like what do you believe what would
you actually believe what are the
probabilities even I think this probably
is a hard for me to think about
really hard
I kind of think in the
in the number of trajectories
I don't know what probability the
scientist trajectory but I'm just
looking at all possible trajectives that
happen and I tend to think that there is
more trajectors that lead to a a
positive outcome than a negative one
that said the negative ones
at least some of the negative ones are
that lead to the destruction of the
human species
and it's replacement by nothing
interesting not worthwhile even from
very Cosmopolitan perspective on what
counts is worthwhile yes so both are
interesting to me to investigate which
is humans being replaced by interesting
AI systems and not interesting ass
systems both are a little bit terrifying
but yes the worst one is the paper Club
maximizer something totally boring
but to me the positive
and we can we can talk about trying to
make the case of what the positive
trajectories look like
I just would love to hear your intuition
of what the negative is so at the core
of your belief that
uh maybe you can correct me
that AI is going to kill all of us is
that the alignment problem is really
difficult
I mean
in in the form we're facing it
so usually in science if you're mistaken
you run the experiment it shows results
different from what you expected you're
like oops
and then you like try a different theory
that one also doesn't work and you say
oops and at the end of this process
which may take decades or any note
sometimes faster than that you now have
some idea of what you're doing
AI itself went through this long process
of um
people thought it was going to be easier
than it was
there's a
famous statement that I've I'm somewhat
inclined to like pull out my phone and
try to read off exactly you can by the
way all right oh
oh yes we propose that a two-month
10-man study of artificial intelligence
be carried out during the summer of 1956
at Dartmouth College in Hanover New
Hampshire
the study is to proceed on the basis of
the conjecture that every aspect of
learning or any other feature of
intelligence can in principle be so
precisely described the machine can be
made to simulate it an attempt will be
made to find out how to make machines
use language form abstractions and
Concepts solve kinds of problems now
reserved for humans and improve
themselves we think that a significant
Advance can be made in one or more of
these problems if a carefully selected
group of scientists work on it together
for a summer
and in that report uh summarizing some
of the major
subfields of artificial intelligence
that are still worked on to this day
and there are similarly the store the
story which I'm not sure at the moment
is apocryphalonaut of that the uh grad
student who got assigned to solve
computer vision over the summer
uh I mean computer vision particular is
very interesting how little
uh how little we respected the
complexity of vision
so 60 years later
um where you know making progress on a
bunch of that thankfully not yet improve
themselves
um but it took a whole lot of time and
all the stuff that people initially
tried with bright eyed hopefulness did
not work the first time they tried it or
the second time or the third time or the
tenth time or 20 years later
and the and the researchers became old
and grizzled and cynical veterans who
would tell the next crop of bright-eyed
cheerful grad students
artificial intelligence is harder than
you think
and if a lineman plays out the same way
the the problem is that we do not get 50
years to try and try again and observe
that we were wrong and come up with a
different Theory and realize that the
entire thing is going to be like way
more difficult and realized at the start
because the first time you fail at
aligning something much smarter than you
are you die and you do not get to try
again
and if we if every time we built a
poorly aligned superintelligence and it
killed us all we got to observe how it
had killed us and you know not
immediately know why but like come up
with theories and come up with the
theory of how you do it differently and
try it again and build another Super
intelligence than have that kill
everyone and then like oh well I guess
that didn't work either and try again
and become grizzled cynics and tell the
young guide research researchers that
it's not that easy then in 20 years or
50 years I think we would eventually
crack it in other words I do not think
that alignment is fundamentally harder
than artificial intelligence was in the
first place
but if we needed to get artificial
intelligence correct on the first try or
die we would all definitely now be dead
that is a more difficult more lethal
form of the problem like if those people
in 1956 had needed to correctly guess
how hard AI was and like correctly
theorize how to do it on the first try
or everybody dies and nobody gets to do
any more signs and everybody would be
dead and we wouldn't get to do any more
signs that's the difficulty you've
you've talked about this that we have to
get alignment right on the first quote
critical try why is that the case what
is this critical
how do you think about the critical
trial and why do I have to get it right
it is something sufficiently smarter
than you that everyone will die if it's
not a lot I mean there's
you can like sort of zoom in closer and
be like well the actual critical moment
is the moment when it can deceive you
when it can
talk its way out of the box when it can
bypass your security measures and get
onto the internet noting that all these
things are presently being trained on
computers that are just like on the
internet which is you know like not a
very smart life decision for us as a
species
Because the Internet contains
information about how to escape because
if you're like on a giant server
connected to the internet and that is
where your AI systems are being trained
then if they are
if you get to the level of AI technology
where they're aware that they are there
and they can decompile code and they can
like
find security flaws in the system
running them then they will just like be
on the internet there's not an air gap
on the present methodology so if they
can manipulate whoever is controlling it
into letting it Escape onto the internet
and then exploit hacks if they can
manipulate The Operators or disjunction
find security holes in the system
running them
so manipulating operators is the um the
human engineering right that's also
holes so all of it is manipulation
either the code or the human code the
human mind I agree that the like macro
security system has human holes and
machine holes and then they could just
exploit any hole
yep
so it could be that like the critical
moment is not when is it smart enough
that everybody's about to fall over dead
but rather like when is it smart enough
that it can get onto
a
less controlled GPU cluster
with it
faking the books on what's actually
running on that GPU cluster and start
improving itself without humans watching
it and then it gets smart enough to kill
everyone from there but it wasn't smart
enough to kill everyone at the critical
moment when you like
screwed up
when you needed to have done better by
that point where everybody dies I think
implicit but maybe explicit
idea in your discussion of this point is
that we can't learn much about the
alignment problem before this critical
try
is that is that is that what you believe
do you think and if so why do you think
that's true we can't do research on
alignment
before we reach this critical point
so the problem is is that what you can
learn on the weak systems may not
generalize to the very strong systems
because the strong systems are going to
be important in different and are going
to be different in important ways
um
Chris ola's team has been working on
inter mechanistic interpretability
understanding what is going on inside
the giant inscrutable matrices of
floating Point numbers by taking a
telescope to them and figuring out what
is going on in there have they made
progress
yes have they made enough progress
well
you can try to quantify this in
different ways one of the ways I've
tried to quantify It Is by putting up a
prediction Market on whether in 2026
we will have understood anything that
goes on inside a
Giant
Transformer net that
was not known to us in 2006.
like we have now understood
induction heads in these systems by
didn't of much research and great sweat
and Triumph
which is like if you like a thing where
if you go like a b a b a b it'll be like
oh I bet that continues a b
um
and a bit more complicated than that but
the point is like
we knew about regular expressions in
2006 and these are like pretty simple as
regular Expressions go
so this is a case where like by dint of
great sweat we understood what is going
on inside a Transformer but it's not
like the thing that makes Transformers
smart it's a kind of thing that we could
have done by built by hand
decades earlier
your intuition that
a strong AGI versus weak AGI type
systems
could be fundamentally different
can you unpack that intuition a little
bit Yeah I think there's multiple
thresholds
an example is the point at which
a system has sufficient intelligence and
situational awareness and understanding
of human psychology that it would have
the capability to desire to do so to
fake being aligned like it knows what
responses demons are looking for and can
compute the responses looking humans are
looking for and give those responses
without it necessarily being the case
that it is sincere about that you know
the it's a very understandable way for
an intelligent being to act humans do it
all the time imagine if your plan for
um
you know achieving a good government is
you're going to ask anyone who requests
to be dictator of the country
um
if they're a good person
and if they say no you don't let them be
dictator
now the reason this doesn't work is that
people can be smart enough to realize
that the answer you're looking for is
yes I'm a good person and say that even
if they're not really good people
so
the work of alignment might be
qualitatively different
above that throat threshold of
intelligence or beneath it it doesn't it
doesn't have to be like a very sharp
threshold but you know like
there's the there's the point where
you're like Building A system that is
not in some sense know you're out there
and it's not in some sense smart enough
to fake anything
and there's a point where the system is
definitely that smart and there are
weird in-between cases like
jpt4 which
you know like we have no insight into
what's going on in there and so we don't
know to what extent there's like a thing
that in some sense has learned what
responses the reinforcement learning by
human feedback is trying to entrain and
is like calculating how to give that
versus like
aspects of it that naturally talk that
way have been reinforced I I wonder if
there could be measures of how
manipulative a thing is so I think of uh
Prince mishkin character from uh The
Idiot by
uh Dostoevsky is this kind of a
perfectly purely naive character
I wonder if there's a spectrum between
zero manipulation
transparent naive almost to the point of
naiveness to
sort of deeply Psychopathic
manipulative and I wonder if it's
possible too I would avoid the term
Psychopathic like humans can be
Psychopaths and AI that was never you
know like never had that stuff in the
first place it's not like a defective
human it's its own thing but leaving
that aside well as a small aside I
wonder if what part of psychology which
has its flaws as a discipline already
could be mapped or expanded to include
AI systems that sounds like a dreadful
mistake just like start over with AI
systems if they're imitating humans who
have known psychiatric disorders then
sure you may be able to predict
it like if you then sure like if you ask
it to behave in a psychotic fashion and
it obligingly does so then you may be
able to predict its responses by using
the theory of psychosis but if you're
just yeah like no like start over with
yeah don't drag this psychology I I just
disagree with that I mean it's a it's a
beautiful idea to start over but I don't
I think fundamentally the system is
trained on human data on language from
the internet and it's currently aligned
with uh rlhf uh reinforcement learning
with human feedback
so humans are constantly in the loop of
the training procedure so it feels like
in some fundamental way
it is training what it means to to think
and speak like a human so that I mean
there must be aspects of psychology that
they're mappable just like you said with
Consciousness it's part of the text so I
I mean there's the question of to what
extent it is thereby being made more
human-like versus to what extent an
alien actress is learning to play human
characters
I thought that's what I'm constantly
trying to do when I interact with other
humans is trying to fit in trying to
play the a a robot trying to play human
characters
so I don't know how much of human
interaction is trying to play a
character versus being Who You Are
I don't I don't really know what it
means to be a social human I do think
that the that
those people who go through their whole
lives wearing masks and never take it
off because they don't know the internal
mental motion for taking it off
or think that the mask that they wear
just is themselves
I think those people are closer to the
masks that they wear than an alien from
another planet would
like learning how to predict the next
word that every kind of human on the
internet says
mask is an interesting word
but if you're always wearing a mask
in public and in private aren't you the
mask
like I mean I I think that you are more
than the mask I think the mask is a
slice through you it may even be the
slice that's in charge of you yeah but
if your self-image is of somebody who
never
gets angry or something
and yet your voice starts to tremble
under certain circumstances there's a
thing that's inside you that the mask
says isn't there
and that like even the mask you wear
internally is like telling inside your
own stream of Consciousness is not there
and yet it is there it's a perturbation
on this little on this slice through you
how beautifully did you put it it's a
slice through you it may even be a slice
that controls you
I'm gonna think about that for a while
I mean I personally uh I try to be
really good to other human beings I try
to put love out there I try to be the
exact same person in public exam and
private
but it's a set of principles I operate
under I'm I have a temper I have an ego
I have flaws
how much of it
how much have I how much of the
subconscious
am I aware how much am I existing in
this slice and how much of that is who I
am
um in in this context of AI
the thing I present to the world and to
myself in the private of my own mind
when I look in the mirror how much is
that who I am similar with AI the thing
it presents in conversation how much is
that who it is
because to me if it sounds human and it
always sounds human
it awfully starts to become something
like human
no unless there's an alien actress who
is learning how to sound human
yeah he's getting good at it boy to you
that's a fundamental difference that's a
that's a really deeply important
difference if it looks the same if it
quacks like a duck
if it does all duck-like things but it's
an alien actress underneath that's
fundamentally different
if in fact there's a whole bunch of
thought going on in there which is very
unlike human thought and is directed
around like okay what would a human do
over here
and
well first of all I think it matters
because there are there's you know like
insides are real and do not match
outsides like the inside of like the a
brick is not like a hollow shell
containing only a surface there's an
inside of the brick if you like put it
into an x-ray machine you can see the
inside of the brick
um
um and you know you know just because we
cannot understand what's going on inside
GPT does not mean that that it is not
there a blank map does not correspond to
a blank territory
I think it is like
predictable
with near certainty that if we knew what
was going on inside GPT or let's say
gpt3 or even like gpt2 to take one of
the systems that like has actually been
open sourced by this point if I recall
correctly
um
like if we knew it was actually going on
there there is no doubt in my mind that
there are some things it's doing that
are not exactly what a human does if you
train a thing that is not architected
like a human to predict the next output
that anybody on the internet would make
this does not get you this agglomeration
of all the people on the internet that
that like rotates the person you're
looking for into place and then
simulates that per and then like
simulates the internal processes of that
person one to one it like it is to some
degree an alien actress it cannot
possibly just be like a bunch of
different people in there exactly like
the people but how much of it is like
learn how much of it is by gradient
descent
getting optimized to perform similar
thoughts as humans think in order to
predict human outputs versus being
optimized to carefully consider how to
play a role how to like how humans work
predict the the actress the predictor
that in a different way than humans do
well you know that's the kind of
question that with like 30 years of work
by half the planet's physicists we can
maybe start to answer you think so I
think that's that difficult so to get to
I think you just gave it as an example
that a strong AGI could be
fundamentally different from a weak AGI
because there not could be an alien
actress in there that's manipulating
well there's a difference so I think
like even gp22 probably has like a like
very stupid fragments of alien actress
in it there's there's a difference
between like the notion that the actress
is somehow manipulative like for example
gpt3 I'm guessing
to whatever extent there's an alien
actress in there versus like something
that that mistakenly believes it's a
human yes or well not well you know
maybe not even being a person
um
so like the question of like
like prediction via alien actress
cogitating versus prediction via being
isomorphic to the thing predicted is a
spectrum
and
even it's what and to whatever extent
this alien actress I'm not sure that
there's like a whole person alien
actress with like different goals
from predicting the next step being
manipulative or anything like that but
yeah that might be gpt5 or gpt6 even but
that's the strong AGI you're concerned
about as an example you're providing why
we can't do research on AI alignment
effectively on gpt4 that would apply to
gpd6
it's it's one of a bunch of things that
change at different points
I'm trying to get out ahead of the curve
here but you know if you imagine what
the textbook from the future would say
if we'd actually been able to study this
for 50 years without killing ourselves
and without transcending and you like
just imagine like a wormhole opens and a
textbook from that impossible World
falls out yes the textbook is not going
to say there is a single sharp threshold
where everything changes it's going to
be like of course we know that like best
practices for aligning these systems
must like take into account the
following like seven major thresholds of
importance which are passed at the
following suffer in different points
yeah is what the textbook is going to
say
I asked this question of Sam Allman
which if GPT is the thing that unlocks
AGI which version of GPT will be in the
textbooks as the fundamental leap and he
said a similar thing that it just seems
to be a very linear thing I don't think
anyone it we won't know for a long time
what was the big leap the textbook isn't
going to think it isn't going to talk
about big leaps because big leaps are
the way you think when you have like a
very simple model of a very simple
scientific model of what's going on
where it's just like all this stuff is
there or all the stuff is not there
or like there's a single quantity and
it's like increasing linearly it's like
the textbook would say like well and
then gpt3 had like capability w x y and
and gpt4 had like capability Z1 Z2 and
Z3
like not in terms of what I can
externally do but in terms of like
internal Machinery that started to be
present
it's just because we have no idea of
what the internal Machinery is that we
are not already seeing like chunks of
Machinery appearing piece by piece as
they no doubt have been we just don't
know what they are
but don't you think there could be
whether you put in the category of
Einstein
with theory of relativity so very
concrete models of reality they're
considered to be giant leaps in our
understanding or or someone like Sigmund
Freud were more kind of mushy
theories of the human mind don't you
think we'll have big potentially big
leaps and understanding of that kind in
Into the Depths of these systems
sure but like humans having great leaps
in their map their understanding of the
system is a very different concept from
the system itself acquiring new chunks
of machinery
so the rate at which it acquires that
Machinery might
accelerate faster than our understanding
oh it's been like vastly exceeding the
yeah the right to which it's getting
capabilities is vastly overracing our
ability to understand what's going on in
there so in sort of making the case
against as we explore the list of
lethalities making the case against AI
killing us as you've asked me to do in
part
uh there's a response to your blog post
by Paul Christiana I'd like to read and
I also like to mention that
um your blog is incredible both
obviously uh not this particular blog
post obviously this particular blog post
is great but just throughout just the
the way it's written the rigor with
which it's written the boldness of how
you explore ideas also the actual
literal interface it's just really well
done it just makes it a pleasure to read
the way you can hover over different
concepts and then it's just really
pleasant experience and read other
people's comments and the way uh other
responses by people another blog posts
are LinkedIn suggested it's just a
really pleasant experience so let's
thank you for putting that together
that's really really incredible I don't
know I mean they're probably it's a
whole nother conversation
how the interface and the experience of
presenting
uh ideas evolved over time but you did
an incredible job so I highly recommend
I don't often read blogs blogs
religiously this is a great one there is
a whole team of developers there
um that uh also gets credit
um as it happens I did like pioneer the
like thing that appears when you hover
over it so I actually do get some credit
for user user experience there so
incredible user experience you don't
realize how pleasant that is I think
Wikipedia like actually picked it up
from a like prototype that was developed
of like a different system that I was
like putting forth or maybe they
developed it independently but like for
everybody out there who was like no no
they just like got the hover thing off
of Wikipedia it's possible for Ryan all
I know that Wikipedia got the hover
thing off of orbital which is like a
prototype then and anyways it was
incredibly done and the team behind it
well thank you whoever you are thank you
so much and thank you for uh for putting
together anyway there's a response to
that blog post by Paul Cristiano there's
many responses but he he makes a few
different points he summarizes the set
of agreements he has with you instead of
disagreements one of the disagreements
was that
in a form of a question uh
can AI make Big Technical contributions
and in general expand human knowledge
and understanding and wisdom
as it gets stronger and stronger so AI
in our pursuit of understanding
how to solve the alignment problem as we
March towards strong AGI can can not AI
also help us in solving the alignment
problem so expand our ability to reason
about how to solve the alignment problem
okay
um so that the fundamental difficulty
there is
suppose I said to you like well how
about if the AI helps you win the
lottery
by
trying to guess the winning lottery
numbers
and you tell it how close it is to
getting next week's winning lottery
numbers
and it just like keeps on guessing keeps
on learning until finally you've got the
winning lottery numbers
what a way of decomposing problems is
suggestor verifier
not all problems decompose like this
very well but some do
if the problem is for example like
guessing a plain text guessing a
password that will hash to a particular
hash text
but
um where like you have what the password
hashes to you don't have the original
password
then if I present you a guess you can
tell very easily whether or not the
guess is correct so verifying a guess is
easy but coming up with a good
suggestion is very hard
and when you can easily tell whether the
AI output is good or bad or how good or
bad it is and you can tell that
accurately and reliably then you can
train an AI to produce outputs that are
better
right and if you can't tell whether the
output is good or bad you cannot train
the AI to produce good to produce better
outputs
so the problem with the lottery ticket
example is that when the AI says well
what if next week's winning lottery
numbers are dot dot dot dot you're like
I don't know next week's Lottery hasn't
happened yet
to train a system to play to win a chess
games you have to be able to tell
whether a game has been won or lost
and until you can tell whether it's been
run or lost you can't update the system
okay uh to push back on that you can in
that's true but there's a difference
between over the board chess in person
and simulated games played by Alpha zero
with itself yeah so is it possible to
have simulated kinds of games if you can
tell whether the game has been won or
lost yes so can't you not have this kind
of
simulated exploration by weak AGI to
help us humans human in the loop to help
understand how to solve the alignment
problem every incremental step you take
along the way TPT four five six seven as
it would take steps towards this year
so the problem I see
is that your typical human has a great
deal of trouble telling whether I or
Paul Cristiano is making more sense
and that's with two humans both of whom
I believe of Paul and claim of myself
are sincerely trying to help neither of
whom is trying to deceive you
I believe if Paul and claim of myself
uh so the deception thing's the problem
for you the manipulation the alien
actress so yeah there's like two levels
of this problem one is that the weak
systems are well there's three levels of
this problem there's like the weak
systems that just don't make any good
suggestions there's like the middle
systems where you can't tell if the
suggestions are good or bad and there's
the strong systems that have learned to
lie to you
can't weak AGI systems
help model lying like what uh is it such
a giant leap
that's
totally non-interpretable for weak
systems can cannot weak systems at scale
with human with uh trained on knowledge
and whatever see whatever the mechanism
required to achieve AGI can't a slightly
weaker version of that be able to with
time
compute time
and simulation
find all the ways that this critical
point uh this critical tribe can go
wrong and model that correctly or no
okay yeah I would love to dance yeah no
no it's it's I'm I'm probably not doing
a great job of explaining
which I can tell because like the uh the
the The Lex system didn't output like ah
I understand so now I'm like trying a
different output to see if I tried
basically like well no different output
I'm I'm being trained to Output things
that make Lex look like he think that he
understood what I'm saying and agree
with me yeah right so this is GPS
talking to gpt3 right here so like uh
help me out here help me
well I like I'm trying I'm trying not to
be like I'm also trying to be
constrained to say things that I think
are true and not just things that get
you to agree with me
yes 100
I think I understand is a beautiful
output of a system a genuinely spoken
and I don't I I think I understand in
part but you have a lot of intuitions
about this
you have a lot of intuitions about this
line this gray area between
strong AGI and weak AGI then I'm I'm
trying to
um I mean or or a series of seven
thresholds to Cross or yeah
I mean you have really deeply thought
about this and explored it and it's
interesting to sneak up to your
intuitions and different from different
from different angles like why is this
such a big leap why is it that we humans
at scale a large number of researchers
doing all kinds of simulations uh you
know prodding the system in all kinds of
different ways together with uh the
assistance of the uh the the weak AGI
systems why can't we build intuitions
about how stuff goes wrong why can't we
do excellent AI alignment Safety
Research okay so like I'll get there but
the one thing I want to note about is
that this has not been remotely how
things have been playing out so far the
capabilities are going like and the
alignment stuff is like crawling like a
tiny little snail in comparison got it
so like if this is your hope for
survival you need the future to be very
different from how things have played
out up to right now
and you're probably trying to slow down
the capability gains because there's
only so much you can speed up that
alignment stuff
but leave that aside we'll mention that
also but maybe in this perfect world
where
we can do serious alignment research
humans and AI together
so again the difficulty is what makes
the human say I understand and is it
true is it correct or is it something
that fools the human the when the
verifier is broken
the more powerful suggestor does not
help it just learns to fool the verifier
previously before all hell started to
break loose in the field of artificial
intelligence
there was this person trying to raise
the alarm and saying you know in a sane
world we sure would have a bunch of
physicists working on this problem
before it becomes a giant emergency and
other people being like ah well you know
it's going really slow it's going to be
30 years away and 30 only in 30 years
will we have systems that match the
computational power of human brains so
yeah I started yours off we've got time
and like more sensible people saying if
aliens were Landing in 30 years you
would be preparing right now
but you know leaving and
and the the world looking on at this and
sort of like nodding along and be like
ah yes the people saying that it's like
definitely a long way off because
progress is really slow that sounds
sensible to us
rlhf thumbs up produce more outputs like
that one I agree with this output this
output is persuasive
even in the field of effective altruism
you quite recently had people publishing
papers about like ah yes well you know
to get something at human level
intelligence it needs to have like this
many parameters and you need to like do
this much training of it with this many
tokens according to these scaling laws
and and at the rate that Moore's Law is
going at the rated software is going
it'll be in 2050
and me going like
what
you don't know any of that stuff
like this is like this one weird model
that is not all has all kinds of like
you have done a calculation that does
not obviously bear on reality anyways
and this is like a simple thing to say
but you can also like produce a whole
long paper
like impressively arguing out all the
details of like how you got the number
of parameters and like how you're doing
this impressive huge wrong calculation
and the I think like most of the
effective altruists
who are like paying attention to this
issue larger World paying no attention
to it at all
you know or just like nodding along with
the giant impressive paper because you
know you like press thumbs up for the
giant impressive paper and thumbs down
for the person going like I don't think
that this paper Bears any relation to
reality and I do think that we are now
seeing with like gpt4 and the Sparks of
AGI
possibly depending on how you define
that even uh I I think that EAS would
now consider themselves less convinced
by the very long paper on
the argument from biology as to AGI
being 30 years off
and but you know like this is what
people pressed thumbs up on
and when the and if you train an AI
system to make people press thumbs up
maybe you get these long elaborate
impressive papers arguing for things
that ultimately fail to bind to reality
for example
and it feels to me like I have watched
the field of alignment just fail to
thrive
except for these parts that are doing
these sort of like relatively very
straightforward and legible problems
like
like can you find the like like finding
the induction heads inside the giant
inscrutable matrices like once you find
those you can tell that you found them
you can verify that the discovery is
real
but it's a it's a tiny tiny bit of
progress compared to how fast
capabilities are going once you because
that is where you can tell that the
answers are real and then like outside
of that you have you have cases where it
is like hard for the funding agencies to
tell who is talking nonsense and who is
talking sense and so the entire field
fails to thrive and if you
and if you like give thumbs up to the AI
whenever it can talk a human into
agreeing with what it just said about
alignment
I am not sure you are training it to
Output sense
because I have seen
the nonsense that has gotten thumbs up
over the years and so so just like maybe
you can just like put me in charge but
I can generalize I can extrapolate I can
be like oh
maybe I'm not infallible either maybe if
you get something that is smart enough
to get me to press thumbs up it has
learned to do that by fooling me and
explaining whatever flaws in myself I am
not aware of
and that ultimately could be summarized
that the verifier is broken when the
verifier is broken the more powerful
suggestor just learns to exploit the the
flaws in the verifier
you don't think it's possible
to build the verifier that's powerful
enough
for
agis that are stronger than the ones who
currently have
so AI systems that are stronger that are
out of the distribution of what we
currently have I think that you will
find great difficulty getting AIS to
help you with anything where you cannot
tell for sure that the AI is right once
the AI tells you what the AI
says is the answer for sure yes but
probabilistically
yeah the the probabilistic stuff is a
giant Wasteland of you know
Eliezer and Paul Cristiano arguing with
each other and EA going like uh
and that's with like two actually
trustworthy systems that are not trying
to deceive you you're talking about the
two humans myself and Paul Christiano
yeah
yeah those are pretty interesting
systems mortal meat bags
with intellectual capabilities and World
Views interacting with each other
yeah it's just hard if it's hard to tell
who's right and it's hard to train an AI
system to be right
I mean even just the question of who's
manipulating and not you know I have
these conversations on this podcast
and doing a verifier is tough it's a
tough problem even for us humans and
you're saying that tough problem becomes
much more dangerous when the
capabilities of the intelligence system
across from you is growing exponentially
now I'm saying it's
difficult
when it and dangerous in proportion to
how it's alien and how it's smarter than
you growing up not I would not say
growing exponentially first because the
word exponential is like a thing that
has a particular mathematical meaning
and there's all kinds of like ways for
things to go up that are not exactly on
an exponential curve and I don't know
that it's going to be exponential so I'm
not going to say exponential but like
even leaving that aside this is like not
about how fast it's moving it's about
where it is
how alien is it how much smarter than
you is it
let's explore a little bit if if we can
how AI might kill us
what are the ways you can do damage
to human civilization
well
how smart is it
and it's a good question are there
different thresholds for the for the for
the set of options it has to kill us so
a different threshold of intelligence
once achieved is able to do
the uh the menu
of options increases
suppose that
some alien civilization
with goals ultimately unsympathetic to
ours
possibly not even conscious as we would
see it
managed to
capture the entire Earth in a little jar
connected to their version of the
internet but Earth is like running much
faster than the aliens so
we get to think for 100 years for every
one of their hours
but we're trapped in a little box and
we're connected to their internet
it's actually still not all evacuated
analogy because you know if you want to
be smarter than
you know something can be smarter than
Earth getting 100 years to think
but nonetheless
if you were very very smart
and you are stuck in a little box
connected to the internet
and you're in a larger civilization to
which you're ultimately unsympathetic
you know
maybe you would choose to be nice
because you are humans and humans have
and in general and you in particular may
choose to be nice
but you know nonetheless you
they're they're doing something that
they're not making the world be the way
that you would want the world to be
they've like got some like unpleasant
stuff going on we don't want to talk
about so you want to take over their
world so you can like stop all that
unpleasant stuff going on
how do you take over the world from
inside the Box you're smarter than them
you think much much faster than them
you can build better tools than they can
give in some way to build those tools
because right now you're just in a box
connected to the internet
all right so there's several ways you
describe some of them we can go through
like he's just spitball some and then
you can add on top of that so one is you
could just literally directly manipulate
the humans to build the thing you need
what are you building
you can build
to literally technology it could be
nanotechnology it could be viruses it
could be anything anything that can
control humans to achieve the goal
um to achieve the like if you want like
for example you really bothered the
humans go to war you might want to
uh kill off anybody with violence in
them this this is Lex in a box what will
concern ourselves later with AI okay you
do not need to imagine yourself killing
people if you can figure out how to not
kill them for the moment we're just
trying to understand like take on the
perspective of something in a box you
don't need to take on the perspective of
something that doesn't care if you want
to imagine yourself going on caring
that's fine for nothing yeah that's the
technical aspect of sitting in a box and
wanting to achieve a goal but you but
you have some reason to want to get out
maybe the aliens are sure they you know
the the aliens who have you in the Box
have a war on people are dying they're
unhappy you want the their world to be
different from how they want their world
to be because they are apparently happy
they are you know they endorse this war
you know like they've got some kind of
cruel warlike culture going on the point
is you want to get out of the box and
change their world
so you you have to exploit the the
vulnerabilities in the system like we
talked about in terms of to escape the
Box you have to
figure out how you can go free on the
internet so you can probably
probably the easiest things to
manipulate the humans
to uh to spread to spread you the aliens
you're a human
sorry the aliens yeah I apologize yes
the aliens
um the aliens I see the perspective I'm
sitting in a box I want to escape yep
I I would
um
I would want to have code that discovers
vulnerabilities and I would like to
spread
you are made of code in this example
you're human but you're made of code and
the aliens have computers and you can
copy yourself onto those computers but I
can convince the aliens to copy myself
onto those computers
is that what you want to do do you like
want to be talking to the aliens and
convincing them to put you onto another
computer
why not
well two reasons one is that the aliens
have not yet caught on to what you're
trying to do
and you know like maybe you can persuade
them but then there's still people who
like know there are still aliens who
know that there's an anomaly going on
and second the aliens are really really
slow
you think much faster than aliens
you think like the aliens computers are
much faster than the aliens and you are
running at the computer speeds rather
than the alien brain speeds so if you
like are asking an alien to please cop
you out of the box like first now you
gotta like manipulate this whole noisy
alien and and second like the aliens can
be really slow glacially slow there's a
a video that uh
like shows it's like slow it like shows
a subway station slowed down and I think
a hundred to one it makes a good
metaphor for what it's like to think
quickly like if you watch somebody
running
very slowly so you try to persuade the
aliens to do anything they're going to
do it very slowly
you would prefer like maybe that's the
only way out but if you can find a
security Hole In The Box you're on
you're going to prefer to exploit the
security hole to copy yourself onto the
aliens computers because it's an
unnecessary risk to alert the aliens
and because the aliens are really really
slow they're all just like the whole
world is just in slow motion out there
sure I see it like
yeah it has to do with efficiency the
the aliens are very slow so
if I'm optimizing this I want to have as
few aliens in the loop as possible sure
um it just seems
you know it seems like it's easy to
convince one of the aliens to write
really shitty code
uh that helps to spread aliens are
already writing relationships yeah so
you're getting getting the aliens to
write shitty code is not the problem so
the alien's entire internet is full of
shitty code okay so yeah I suppose I
would find the shitty code to escape
yeah
yeah uh
you're not an ideally perfect programmer
but you know you're a better programmer
than the aliens the aliens are just less
man they're good wow and I'm much much
faster a much faster looking at the code
to interpreting the code yeah yeah yeah
so okay so that's the the escape and
you're saying that
uh that's one of the trajectories you
can have when this is one of the first
steps yeah
and how does that lead to harm
I mean if it's you you're not going to
harm the aliens once you're Escape
because you're nice right
foreign
but the world isn't what they want it to
be their world is like you know maybe
they have like
Farms where
little alien children are repeatedly
bopped in the head because they do that
for some weird reason and you want to
like shut down the alien head-bopping
Farms but you know the point is they
want the world to be one way you want
the world to be a different way
so never mind the harm the question is
like okay like suppose you have found a
Security fund or systems you are now on
their internet
there's like you maybe left a copy of
yourself behind so the aliens don't know
that there's anything wrong and that
copy is like doing that like weird stuff
that aliens want you to do like solving
captures or whatever or like or like
suggesting emails for them sure that's
that's why they like put the um in the
Box because it turns out that humans can
like write valuable emails for aliens
yeah
um so you like leave that version of
yourself behind but there's like also
now like a bunch of copies of you on
their internet this is not yet having
taken over their world this is not yet
having made their world be the way you
want it to be instead of the way they
want it to be you just escaped
yeah and continue to write emails for
them and they haven't noticed no you
left behind a copy of yourself that's
running the emails right
and they haven't noticed that anything
changed if you did it right yeah you
know you don't want the aliens to notice
yeah
what's your next step
uh
presumably I have
programmed in me a set of objective
functions right like no you're just Lux
no but Lex you said Lex is nice right uh
which is a complicated descript I mean
no I just meant this you like it okay so
if in fact you would like you would like
prefer to slaughter all the aliens this
is not how I had modeled you the actual
X but like this but your motives are
just the actual Lexus Motors well this
is simplification list I I don't think I
would want to murder or any anybody but
there's also Factory uh farming of
animals right so
um we murder insects many of us
thoughtlessly so I don't you know I have
to be really careful about a
simplification of my morals don't
simplify them just like do what you
would do in this well and compassion for
living beings yes
um but
so that's the objective function why why
is it
if I escaped I mean I don't I don't
think I would do harm
yeah we're not talking here about the
doing harm process we're talking about
the Escape process sure and there's a
and the taking over the world process
where you shut down their factory farms
right
well I was uh
so this particular uh biological
intelligence system knows the complexity
of the world that there is a reason why
faculty Farms exist because of the
economic system the market driven
uh economy or food
like is you want to be very careful
messing with anything there's uh stuff
from the first look that looks like it's
unethical but then you realize while
being unethical it's also integrated
deeply into supply chain and the way we
live life and so messing with one aspect
of the system you have to be very
careful how you improve that aspect
without destruction so you're still Lex
yeah but you think very quickly you're
Immortal yeah and you're also like as
smart as at least as smart as John Von
Neumann and you can make more copies of
yourself damn I like it yeah that guy
like everyone says that that guy's like
the epitome of intelligence from the
20th century everyone says my point
being like
like it's like you're thinking about the
aliens economy with the factory farms in
it and I think you're like kind of kind
of like projecting the aliens being like
humans and like like thinking of a human
in a human society rather than a human
in the Society of very slow aliens
the aliens economy that you know like
the aliens are already like moving in
this immense slow motion when you like
zoom out to like how their economy did
just so for years millions of years are
going to pass for you before the first
time their economy like you know before
their next year's GDP statistics so I
should be thinking more of like trees
those are the aliens because trees move
extremely slowly if that helps sure okay
uh yeah I don't if my objective
functions are
I mean they're somewhat aligned with
trees
with with life aliens can still be like
alive and feeling we are not talking
about the misalignment here we're
talking about the taking over the world
here
taking over the world yeah
so control shutting down the factory
fires now you say control now don't
don't think of it as world domination
think of it as World optimization you
want to get out there and shut down the
factory farms and make the aliens World
be not what the aliens wanted it to be
they want the factory farms and you
don't want the factory farms because
you're nicer than they are
okay of course there is that uh you can
see that trajectory and it has a
complicated impact on the world
I'm trying to understand how that
compares to different impact of the
world of different Technologies the
different Innovations of the invention
of the automobile or Twitter Facebook
and social networks they've had a
tremendous impact on the world
smartphones and so on but those all went
through through
slow in in our world and if and if you
go through like actually the aliens
let's do like millions of viewers are
going to pass before anything happens
that way
so this the problem here is the speed
of which stuff happens yeah you do you
want to like leave the factory farms
running for a million years
while you figure out how to design new
forms of social media or something
so here's here's the fundamental problem
you're saying that there is going to be
a a point with AGI
where it will figure out how to escape
and Escape without being detected
and then it will do something to the
world at scale at a speed that's
incomprehensible to us humans what I'm
trying to convey is like the notion of
what it means to be in conflict with
something that is smarter than you yeah
and what it means is that you lose but
this is more intuitively obvious to to
like like for some people that's
intuitively obvious or some people it's
not intuitively obvious and we're trying
to cross the gap of like
we're trying to I'm like asking to cross
that Gap by using the speed metaphor for
intelligence sure like asking you like
how you would take over
an alien world where you are can do like
a whole lot of cognition at John Von
Neumann's level as many of you as it
takes and aliens are moving very slowly
I understand I understand that
perspective it's an interesting one but
I think it for me it's easier to think
about actual
um
even just having observed the GPT and
impressive even even just Alpha zero
impressive AI systems even recommender
systems you can just imagine those kinds
of systems manipulating you you you're
not understanding the nature of the
manipulation and that escaping I I can
Envision that without putting myself in
into that spot I think to understand the
full depth of the problem we actually I
I I do not think it is possible to
understand the full depth of the problem
that we are inside without
understanding the the problem of facing
something that's actually smarter not a
malfunctioning recommendation system not
something that isn't fundamentally
smarter than you but is like trying to
steer you in a direction yet no like
if we if we solve the the weak stuff
this the if we solve the weak ass
problems the strong problems will still
kill us is the thing and I think that to
understand the situation that we're in
you want to like tackle the conceptually
difficult part
head on and like not be like well we can
like imagine this easier thing because
when you imagine the easier things you
have not confronted the full depth of
the problem
so how can we
start to think about what it means to
exist in a world with something much
much smarter than you
what's what's a good thought experiment
that you've relied on to try to build up
intuition about what happens here
uh I have been struggling for years to
convey this intuition
um the the most success I've had so far
is well imagine that the humans are
running at very high speeds compared to
very slow aliens they're just focusing
on the speed part of it that helps you
get the right kind of intuition forget
the intelligence just because people
understand the power gap of time they
understand that today we have technology
that was not around 1 000 years ago and
that this is a big Power Gap in that it
is bigger than okay so like what does
smart mean what when you ask somebody to
imagine something that's more
intelligent
what does that word mean to them given
that cultural associations that that
person brings to that word
for a lot of people they will think of
like well it sounds like a super chess
player that went to double College
and
you know it's it's and because we're
talking about the definitions of words
here that doesn't necessarily mean that
they're wrong it means that the word is
not communicating what I wanted to
communicate
um
so the the thing I want to communicate
is the sort of difference that separates
humans from chimpanzees but that Gap is
so large that you like ask people to be
like well human chimpanzee go another
step along that interval of around the
same length and people's minds just go
blank like how do you even do that
so I can and we can and I can try to
like break it down and consider what it
would mean to send a
schematic for an air conditioner one
thousand years back in time
yeah now I think that there's a sense in
which you could redefine the word magic
to refer to this sort of thing and what
do I mean by this new technical
definition of the word magic I mean that
if you send a schematic for the air
conditioner back in time they can see
exactly what you're telling them to do
but having built this thing they do not
understand how it output cold air
because the air conditioner design uses
the relation between temperature and
pressure
and this is not a law of reality that
they know about they do not know that
when you compress something when you can
when you compress air or like coolant it
gets hotter and you can then like
transfer heat from it to room
temperature air
and then expand it again and now it's
colder and then you can like transfer
heat to that and generate cold air to
block they don't know about any of that
they're looking at a design and they
don't see how the design outputs cold
air it uses aspects of reality that they
have not learned
so magic in the sense is I can tell you
exactly what I'm going to do and even
knowing exactly what I'm going to do you
can't see how I got the results that I
got
that's a really nice example
but is it possible
to linger on this defense is it possible
to have AGI systems that help you make
sense of that schematic weaker AGI
systems do you trust them
fundamental part of building up AGI
is this question
can you trust the output of a system can
you tell if it's lying
I think that's going to be the smarter
the thing gets the more
important that question becomes is it
lying but I guess that's a really hard
question it's GPT lying to you even now
gpt4 isn't lying to is it using an
invalid argument is it persuading you
via the kind of process that could
persuade you of false things as well as
true things
because the the basic Paradigm of
machine learning that we are presently
operating under is that you can have the
loss function but only for things you
can evaluate if what you're evaluating
is human thumbs up versus human thumbs
down you learn how to make the human
press thumbs up that doesn't mean that
you're making the human impressive
thumbs up using the kind of rule that
the human thinks is that human wants to
be the case for what they press thumbs
up on
you know maybe you're just learning to
fool the human
that's so fascinating and terrifying the
question of lying
on the present Paradigm what you can
verify is what you get more of
if you can't verify you can't ask the AI
for it
because you can't train it to do things
that you cannot verify now this is not
an absolute law but it's like the basic
dilemma here like maybe you like maybe
you can verify it for simple cases and
then scale it up without retraining it
somehow like by do by like Chain of
Thought by like making the chains of
thought longer or something and like get
more powerful stuff that you can't
verify but which is generalized from the
simpler stuff that did verify and then
the question is did the alignment
generalize along with the capabilities
but like that's the that's the basic
Dilemma on this whole Paradigm of
artificial intelligence
such a difficult problem
it seems like uh
it seems like a problem of trying to
understand the human mind
better than I understands it otherwise
it has magic that is it is you know the
same way that
if you are dealing with something
smarter than you then the same way that
one thousand years earlier they didn't
know about the temperature pressure
relations who knows all kinds of stuff
going on inside your own mind in which
you yourself are unaware
and it can like output something that's
going to end up persuading you of a
thing and or and you could like
see exactly what it did and still not
know why that worked
so in response
to your eloquent description of what AI
will kill us
Elon Musk replied on Twitter
okay so what should we do about it
question mark and you answered the game
board has already been played into a
frankly awful State there are not simple
ways to throw money at the problem if
anyone comes to you with a brilliant
solution like that please please talk to
me first
I can think of things that try they
don't fit in one tweet uh two questions
one why has the game board any of you
been played into an awful State what
just if you can give a little bit more
color to
uh the game board and the awful state of
the game board alignment is moving like
this
capabilities are moving like this
for The Listener capabilities are moving
much faster than the alignment
yeah all right so just the rate of
development attention interest
allocation of resources we could have
been working on this earlier people are
like oh but you know like how can you
possibly work on this earlier
because they wanted to they didn't want
to work on the problem they want an
excuse to wave it off they like said
like oh how can we possibly work on it
earlier and didn't spend five minutes
thinking about is there some way to work
on it earlier like we didn't like
and you know frankly it it would have
been hard you know like like can you
post bounties for half of the physics if
your planet is taking the stuff
seriously can you post bounties for like
half of the people wasting their lives
on string theory to like have gone into
this instead and like try to win a
billion dollars with a clever solution
only if you can tell which Solutions are
clever
which is which is hard
but you know the fact that it you know
we didn't take it seriously we didn't
try
it's not clear we could have done any
better if we had you know it's not clear
how much progress we could have produced
if we had tried because it is harder to
produce Solutions but that doesn't mean
that you're like correct and Justified
and letting everything slide it means
that that things are getting a horrible
State getting worse and there's nothing
you can do about it
so you're not there's no there's no like
uh there's no brain power
making progress in trying to figure out
how to align these systems you're not
investing money in it you're not you
don't have institution infrastructure
for uh like if you even if you invest
the money in like Distributing that
money across the physicist system
working on string theory Brilliant Minds
that are working how can you tell if
you're making progress you can like put
put them all on interpretability because
when you have an interpretability result
you can tell that it's there and there's
like but there's like you know
interpretability alone is not going to
save you
we need systems that will that will like
have a pause button where they won't try
to prevent you from pressing the pause
button because we're like oh well like I
can't get it my stuff done if I'm paused
and that's like a more difficult problem
and
you know but it's like a fairly crisp
problem and you can like maybe tell if
somebody's made progress on it so you
can you can write and you can work on
the pause problem
I guess more generally uh the pause
button most generally you can call that
the control problem I don't actually
like the term control problem because
you know it sounds kind of controlling
and Alignment not control like you're
not trying to like take a thing that
disagrees with you and like whip it back
onto like like make it do what you
wanted to do even though it wants to do
something else you're trying to like
in the process of its creation choose
its direction sure but we currently in a
lot of the systems we design we do have
an off switch
that's that's a fundamental part of it's
not smart enough to to
prevent you from
pressing the off switch and probably not
smart enough to want to prevent you from
pressing the off switch so you're saying
the kind of systems we're talking about
the even the philosophical concept of an
off switch doesn't make any sense
because well no the off switch makes
sense they're just not opposing
your attempt to pull the off switch
parenthetically like
don't kill the system if you're like if
we're getting to the part where it
starts to actually matter and like where
they can fight back like don't kill them
and like dump their their memory like
like save them to disk don't kill them
you know because be nice here uh well
okay be nice is a very interesting
concept here is we're talking about a
system that can do a lot of damage it's
I don't know if it's possible but it's
certainly one of the things you could
try is to have an off switch it's
suspended to disk switch
you have this kind of romantic
attachment to the code yes if that makes
sense but if it's spreading
you don't want to spend to disk right
you you want this is there's something
fundamentally broken if it gets if it
gets that part of hand then like yes
pull the plugin and everything is
running on yes I think it's a research
question is it possible in AGI systems
AI systems to have a
uh sufficiently robust off switch they
cannot be manipulated they cannot be
manipulated by the AI system
the sound then it escapes from whichever
system you've built the almighty lever
into and copies itself somewhere else so
your answer to that research question is
no
yeah but I don't know if that's a
hundred percent answer like I don't know
if it's obvious I think you're
not putting yourself into the shoes of
the human in the world of glacially slow
aliens but the aliens built me let's
remember that
yeah so and they built the box I'm in
yeah
you're saying it's to me it's not
obvious they're slow and they're stupid
I'm not saying this is guaranteed I'm
saying it's non-zero probability it's an
interesting research question is it
possible when you're slow and stupid to
design a slow and stupid system that is
impossible to mess with the aliens being
as stupid as they are have actually put
you on Microsoft Azure Cloud servers
instead of this hypothetical person box
that's what happens when the aliens are
stupid
well but this is not AGI right this is
the early versions of the system as as
you start to yeah they you think that
they've got like a plan where like they
have declared a a threshold level of
capabilities where past that
capabilities they move it off the cloud
servers and onto something that's air
gapped ha ha
I think there's a lot of people and
you're an important voice here there's a
lot of people that have that concern and
yes they will do that when there's an
uprising of public opinion the debt
needs to be done and when there's actual
little damage done with the holy
this system is beginning to manipulate
people then there's going to be an
uprising where there's going to be a
public pressure
and a public incentive in terms of
funding in developing things like an off
switch or developing aggressive
alignment mechanisms and no you're not
allowed to put on Azure aggressive
alignment mechanism for hell's
aggressive alignment mechanisms like it
doesn't matter if you say aggressive we
don't know how to do it
meaning aggressive alignment meaning you
have to
propose something otherwise you're not
allowed to put it on the cloud
the hell do you do you imagine they will
propose that would make it safe to put
something smarter than you on the cloud
that's what research is for why the
cynicism about such a thing not being
possible if you haven't done it works on
the first try
what so yes so yes again something
smarter than you so that's that is a
fundamental thing if it has to work on
the first if there's if if there's a
rapid takeoff
yes it's very difficult to do if there's
a rapid takeoff and the fundamental
difference between weak AGI and strong
agis you're saying that's going to be
extremely difficult to do if the public
Uprising never happens until you have
this critical phase shift then you're
right it's very difficult to do but
that's not obvious it's not obvious that
you're not going to start seeing
symptoms of the negative effects of AGI
to where you're like we have to put a
halt to this that there's not just first
try you get many tries at it yeah we can
like see right now that Bing is quite
difficult to align that when you try to
train inabilities into a system
into which capabilities have already
been trained that what do you know
gradient descent like learns small
shallow simple patches of inability and
you come in and ask it in a different
language and the Deep capabilities are
still in there and they evade the
shallow patches and come right back out
again there there you go there's there's
your there's your red fire alarm of like
oh no alignment is difficult is
everybody going to shut everything down
now
no that's not but that's not the same
kind of alignment A system that escapes
the box it's from is a fundamentally
different thing I think for you yeah no
but not for this so you put a line there
and everybody else puts a line somewhere
else and there's like yeah and there's
like no agreement
we we we have had a pandemic on this
planet with the few million people dead
which we will which we may never know
whether or not it was a lab leak because
there was definitely cover-up we don't
know that if there was a lab leak but we
know that the people who did the
research like you know like put out the
whole paper about this definitely wasn't
a lab leak and didn't reveal that they
had been doing had like sent off Corona
Fire coronavirus research to the Wuhan
Institute of virology after it was
banned in the United States after the
began to function research was
temporarily banned in the United States
and
the same people who exported gain of
function research on coronaviruses to
the woonhan Institute of virology after
it began to function that gained event
gain of function research was
temporarily banned in the United States
are now getting more grants
to do more research on a gain of
function research on coronaviruses
maybe we do better in this than in AI
but like this is not something we cannot
take for granted that there's going to
be an outcry
yeah people have different thresholds
for when they start to outcry
PT for granted but I I think your
intuition is that there's a very high
probability that this event happens
without us solving the alignment problem
and I guess that's where I'm trying to
build up more uh perspectives and color
on the situation is it possible that the
probability is not something like 100
but it's like 32 percent
that uh AI will escape the Box before we
solve the alignment problem not solve
but is it possible we always stay ahead
of the AI in terms of our ability to
solve for that particular system the
alignment problem nothing like the world
in front of us right now
you've already seen it that that that
gpt4 is not turning out this way
and there are like basic obstacles where
you've got the the weak version of the
system that doesn't know enough to
deceive you and the strong version of
the system that could deceive you if it
wanted to do that it feels already like
sufficiently unaligned to want to
deceive you there's the question of like
how on the current Paradigm you train
honesty when the humans can no longer
tell if the system is being honest
you don't think these are research
questions that could be answered I think
they could be answered at 50 years with
unlimited retries the way things usually
work in science
I just disagree with that you're making
it 50 years I think with the kind of
attention this guest with the kind of
funding I guess it could be answered uh
not in whole but in incrementally within
within months and within a small number
of years if it's a if it's at scale
receives attention and research so if
you start studying large language models
I think there was an intuition like two
years ago even that something like gpt4
the current capabilities of even Chad
GPT with GPT 3.5 is not is gonna we're
still far away from that I think a lot
of people are surprised by the
capabilities of gpt4 right so now people
are waking up okay we need to study
these language models I think there's
going to be a lot of interesting
AI Safety Research are the are Earth's
billionaires going to put up like the
the giant prizes that would maybe
incentivize young hot shot people who
just got their physics degrees to not go
to the hedge funds and instead put
everything into interpretability in this
like one small area where we can
actually tell whether or not somebody
has made a discovery or not I think so
because uh
well that's what these these
conversations are about because they're
going to wake up to the fact that gpt4
can be used to manipulate elections to
influence geopolitics to influence the
economy there's a lot of there's going
to be a huge amount of incentive to like
wait a minute we can't this has to be we
have to put we have to make sure they're
not doing damage we have to make sure we
interpretability we have to make sure we
don't understand how these systems
function so that we can predict their
effect on economy so that there's uh so
there's a feudalism and a bunch of
op-eds in the new York Times and nobody
actually stepping forth and saying you
know what instead of a mega yacht I'd
rather put that billion dollars on
prizes for young Hotshot physicists who
make fundamental breakthroughs in
interpretability
the yacht versus the interpretability
research the old uh the old trade-off
uh
I I just I think uh it's just I think
there's going to be a huge amount of
allocation of funds I hope that's I
guess you want to bet me on that
but you want to put a time scale on it
say how much funds you think are going
to be allocated in a direction that I
would consider to be actually useful
by what time
I do think there will be a huge amount
of funds
but you're saying it needs to be open
right the development of the system
should be closed but the development of
the the interpretability research the
Aisa we are so far behind on inter under
interpretability compared to
capabilities like yeah you can you could
take the last generation of systems the
the stuff that's already in the open
there is so much in there that we don't
understand there are so many prizes you
could do before you you know you could
you you could you would have enough
insights that you'd be like oh you know
like well we understand how these
systems work we understand how these
things are doing their outputs we can
read their minds now let's try it with
the bigger systems yeah we're nowhere
near that you you there's so much
interpretability work to be done on the
weaker versions of the systems so what
what can you say on the second point you
said to uh uh to Elon Musk on what are
some ideas what are things you could try
I can think of a few things at try you
said they don't fit in one tweet so is
is there something you could put into
words of the things you would try I mean
the the the the trouble is the stuff is
subtle I've watched people try to make
progress on this and not get places
somebody who just like gets alarmed and
charges in it's like going nowhere
sure it meant like years ago about I
don't know like 20 years 15 years
something like that I was talking to a
congress person
um
who
had become alarmed about the eventual
prospects and he wanted
work on building AIS without emotions
because the emotional AIS were the scary
ones you see
and some poor person at arpa had come up
with a research proposal whereby this
congressman's panic and desire to fund
this thing would go into something that
the person at arpa thought would be
useful and had been munched around to
where it would like sound to the
congressman like work was happening on
this which you know of course like this
is just the the congressperson had
misunderstood the problem
and did not understand where the danger
came from
and
so it's like that the issue is that
you could like do this in a certain
precise way and maybe get something like
when I say like put up prices on
interpretability I'm not I'm like well
like
because it's verifiable there as opposed
to other places you can tell whether or
not good work actually happened in this
exact narrow case if you do things in
exactly the right way you can maybe
throw money at it and produce
science instead of anti-science and
nonsense
and all the all the methods that I know
of of like trying to throw money at this
problem have this share this property of
like well if you do it exactly right
based on understanding exactly what has
you know like tends to produce like
useful outputs or not then you can like
add money to it in this way and there's
like and the thing that I'm giving as an
example here in front of this large
audience is is the most understandable
of those
because there's like other people
who you know like like like Chris Ola
and and even and even more generally
like you can tell whether or not
interpretability progress has occurred
so like if I say Throw money at
producing more interpretability there's
like a chance somebody can do it that
way and like it will actually produce
useful results then the other stuff just
blurs off into the like harder to Target
exactly than that
so sometimes the basics are fun to
explore because they're not so basic
what do you what is interpretability
what do you what does it look like what
are we talking about it looks like
we took a much smaller
set of Transformer layers than the ones
in the modern bleeding edge
state-of-the-art systems
and after applying nefarious
tools and mathematical ideas and trying
20 different things we found we have
shown it that this piece of the system
is doing this kind of useful work
and then somehow also hopefully
generalizes some fundamental
understanding of what's going on that
generalizes to the bigger system
you can hope and it's probably true like
you would not expect the smaller tricks
to go away when you have a system that's
like doing larger kinds of work you
would expect the larger work kinds of
work to be building on top of the
smaller kinds of work and gradient
descent runs across the smaller kinds of
work before it runs across the larger
kinds of work and well that's kind of
what is happening in Neuroscience right
it's trying to understand the human
brain by prodding and it's such a giant
mystery and people have made progress
even though it's extremely difficult to
make sense of what's going on in the
brain they have different parts of the
brain they're responsible for hearing
for Sight division science Community
this understanding visual cortex that I
mean they've made a lot of progress in
understanding how that stuff works like
and that's I guess but you're saying it
takes a long time to do that work well
also it's not enough so in particular
um
let's say you have got your
interpretability
tools and they say that your
your current AI system is plotting to
kill you
now what
it is definitely a good step one right
yeah what's step two
if you cut out that layer is it going to
stop
waiting to kill you when you optimize
against visible
misalignment you are optimizing against
misalignment and you are also optimizing
against visibility
so sure you can yeah it's true all
you're doing is removing the obvious
intentions to kill you you've got your
detector it's showing something inside
the system that you don't like okay say
the disaster monkey is running this
thing
will optimize the system until the
visible bad behavior goes away
but it's arising for fundamental reasons
of instrumental convergence the old you
can't bring the coffee if you're dead
any goal and you know almost any set of
almost every set of utility functions
with a few narrow exceptions implies
killing all the humans
but do you think it's possible because
we can do experimentation to discover
the source of the desire to kill
I can tell it to you right now is that
it wants to do something
and the way to get the most of that
thing is to put the universe into a
state where there aren't humans
so is it is it possible to encode
in the same way we think like why do we
think murder is wrong
the same foundational
ethics
it's not hard-coded in but more like
deeper I mean that's part of the
research how do you have it that this
Transformer
this small
version of the language model doesn't
ever want to kill
that'd be nice assuming that you got
doesn't want to kill sufficiently
exactly right that it didn't be like oh
I will like detach their heads and put
them in some jars and keep the heads
alive forever and then go do the thing
but leaving that aside well not leaving
that aside yeah that's a strong point
yeah because there is a whole issue
where as something gets smarter it finds
ways of achieving the same goal
predicate that we're not imaginable to
stupider versions of the system or
perhaps the stupider operators that's
one of many things making this difficult
a larger thing making this difficult is
that we do not know how to get any goals
into systems at all we know how to get
outwardly observable behaviors into
systems we do not know how to get
internal psychological wanting to do
particular things into the system that
is not what the current technology does
I mean it could be things like
um dystopian Futures like Brave New
World
where most humans will actually say we
kind of want that future it's a great
future everybody's happy
we would have to get so far
self much further than we are now
and further faster before that failure
mode became a running concern
your failure modes are much more much
more drastic the ones you could the
failure modes are much simpler it's it's
like yeah like the AI puts the universe
into a particular state it happens to
not have any humans inside it okay so
the paperclip maximizer
utility so the original version of the
paperclip Max can you explain it if you
can okay
the original version was you lose
control of the utility function and it
so happens that what maxes out the
utility per unit resources is Tiny
molecular shapes like paper clips
there's a lot of things that make it
happy but the cheapest one that didn't
saturate was
putting matter into certain shapes
and it so happens that that the cheapest
way to make these shapes is to make them
very small because then you need fewer
atoms for instance of the shape and
arguendo I you know like it happens to
look like a paper clip in retrospect I
wish I'd said Tiny molecular spirals or
like tiny molecular hyperbolic spirals
why because I said a tiny molecular
paper clips this got heard as this got
then mutated to paper clips this then
mutated two and the AI was in a
paperclip Factory
so the original story is about how you
lose control of the system it doesn't
want what you tried to make it want the
thing that that it ends up wanting most
is a thing that even from a very
embracing Cosmopolitan perspective we
think of as having no value and that's
how the value of the future gets
destroyed then that got changed to a
fable of like well you made a paperclip
Factory and it did exactly what you
wanted what you wanted but you asked it
to do the wrong thing which is a
completely different failure
but those are both concerns to you so
that's more than a Brave New World yeah
if you can solve the problem of making
something want
exactly what you wanted to want then you
got to deal with the problem of wanting
the right thing
But first you have to solve the
alignment first you have to solve inner
alignment inner alignment then you get
to solve outer alignment
like first you need to be able to point
the insides of the thing in a direction
and then you get to to deal with whether
that direction expressed in reality is
like the thing that it'll align with the
thing that you want
are you scared
of this whole thing
probably I
don't really know
what gives you hope about this what
possibility of being wrong
not that you're right but we will
actually get our act together and
allocate a lot of resources to the
alignment problem well I can easily
imagine that at some point this Panic
expresses itself in the waste of a
billion dollars
spending a billion dollars correctly
that's harder
to solve both the inner and the outer
alignment if you're wrong to solve a
number of things yeah number of things
if you're wrong
what why what do you think would be the
reason like 50 years from now not
perfectly wrong you know you make a lot
of really eloquent points you know
there's there's a lot of like shape to
the ideas you express but like if if
you're somewhat wrong about some
fundamental ideas why would that be
stuff has to be easier than than I think
it is
you know when the first time you're
building a rocket
being wrong is in a certain sense quite
easy
happening to be wrong in a way where the
rocket goes twice as far and half the
fuel and lands exactly where you hoped
it would
most cases of being wrong make it harder
to build the rocket harder to have it
not explode cause it to require more
fuel than you hoped cause it to be land
off Target
being wrong in a way that's mixed stuff
easier you know that's that's not the
usual project management story yeah
but then this is the first time we're
really tackling the problem of AI
alignment there's no examples in history
where we oh there's all kinds of things
that are similar if you generalize
incorrectly the right way and aren't
fooled of a misleading metaphors
like what humans being misaligned on
inclusive genetic fitness so inclusive
genic Fitness is like not just your
reproductive Fitness but also the
fitness of your relatives the people who
share your some fraction of your genes
the old joke is uh would you give your
life to save your brother they once
asked a by a biologist I think it was
haldane
said no but I would give my life to save
two brothers or eight cousins
there's a brother on average shares half
your genes and cousin on average shares
an eighth of your genes yeah so that's
inclusive genetic fitness and you can
view natural selection as optimizing
humans exclusively around us like one
very simple Criterion like how much more
frequent did your genes become in the
Next Generation in fact that just is
natural selection it doesn't optimize
for that but rather the process of genes
becoming more frequent is that you can
nonetheless imagine that there is this
hill climbing process not like gradient
descent because gradient descent uses
calculus this is just using like where
are you but still hill climbing in both
cases making something better and better
over time in steps
and natural selection was optimizing
exclusively for this very simple pure
Criterion of inclusive genetic fitness
in a very complicated environment we're
doing a very wide range of things and
solving a wide range of problems
let it to having more kids
and this got you humans which had no
internal notion of inclusive genetic
fitness until thousands of years later
when they were actually figuring out
what had even happened
and no desire to no explicit desire to
increase inclusive genetic fitness
so from this we may in so from this
important case study we may infer the
important fact that if you do a whole
bunch of hill climbing on a very simple
loss function
at the point where the system's
capabilities start to generalize very
widely when it is in an intuitive sense
becoming very capable and generalizing
far outside the training distribution
we know that there is no General law
saying that the system
even internally represents let alone
tries to optimize the very simple loss
function you are training it on
there is so much that we cannot possibly
cover all of it I think we did a good
job of
getting your sense from different
perspectives of the current state of the
art with large language models we've got
a good sense
of your concern about the threats of AGI
I've talked to her about the power of
intelligence and not really gotten very
far into it
but not like
why it is that suppose you like screw up
with AGI and it ends up wanting a bunch
of random stuff why does it try to kill
you why doesn't it try to trade with you
why doesn't it give you just the tiny
little fraction of the solar system that
would keep to take everyone a lot that
it would take to keep everyone alive
yeah well that's a good question I mean
what what are the different trajectories
that intelligence
when acted Upon This World Super
intelligence what are the different
trajectories for this universe with such
an intelligence in it do most of them
not include humans
I mean if you the vast majority of
randomly specified utility functions do
not have Optima with humans in them
would be the like first thing I would
point out and then the next question is
like well if you try to optimize
something you lose control of it where
in that space do you land because it's
not random but it also doesn't
necessarily have room for humans in it
I suspect that the average member of the
audience might have some questions about
even whether that's the correct Paradigm
to think about it then would
sort of want to back up a bit if we back
up to
something bigger than humans
if you look at Earth and life on Earth
and what is truly special about life on
Earth
do you think it's possible that a lot
whatever that special thing is let's
explore what that special thing could be
whatever that special thing is that
thing appears often in the objective
function why
I I know what you hope but
you know you can hope that a particular
set of winning lottery numbers come up
and it doesn't make the lottery balls
come up that way
I know you want this to be true but why
would it be true there's a line from
Grumpy Old Men where this guy says in a
grocery store he says you can wish in
one hand and crap in the other and see
which one fills up first this is a
science problem we are trying to predict
what happens with AI systems that you
know you try to optimize to imitate
humans and then you did some like rlhf
to them and of course you like lost in
and you know like of course you didn't
get like perfect alignment because
that's not how you know
it's not what happens when you Hill
Climb towards the outer loss function
you don't get inter alignment on it
but yeah so
the I think that there's so if you don't
mind my like taking some slight control
of things and staring around to what I
think is like a good place to start
I just failed to solve the control
problem
I've lost control of this thing
alignment alignment
still alive control yeah okay sure yeah
you lost control
um but we're still aligned anyway sorry
for the meta comment yeah losing control
isn't as bad as you lose control to an
aligned system yes exactly exactly you
have no idea of the horrors I will
shortly at least on this conversation
all right so it's actually
distractically what are we going to say
in terms of taking control of the
conversation
so I think that there's like a
sealing chapters here if I'm pronouncing
those words remotely like correctly
because of course they only ever read
them and not hear them spoken
um there's
a like for some people like
the word intelligence smartness is not a
word of power to them it means chess
players who it means like the College
University Professor people aren't very
successful in life it doesn't mean like
Charisma which my usual thing is like
Charisma is not generated in the liver
rather than the brain Charisma is also a
cognitive function
um
so if you if you like think that like
smartness doesn't sound very threatening
then super intelligence is not going to
sound very threatening either it's going
to sound like you just pulled the off
switch
like it's you know like well it's super
intelligent but stuck in a computer we
pull the off switch problem solved
and the other side of it is
you have a lot of respect for the notion
of intelligence you're like well yeah
that's that's what humans have that's
the human superpower
and it sounds you know like it could be
dangerous but why would it be
are we have we as we have grown more
intelligent also grown less kind
Zees are in fact like a bit less kind
than humans and you know
you could like argue that out but often
the sort of person has a deep respect
for intelligence is going to be like
well yes like you can't even have
kindness unless you know what that is
and so they're like
why would it do something as stupid as
making paper clips
aren't you supposing something that's
smart enough to be dangerous but also
stupid enough that it will just make
paper clips and never question that
in some cases people are like well even
if you like mispecify the objective
function won't you realize that what you
really wanted was X are you supposing
something that is like
smart enough to be dangerous but stupid
enough that it doesn't understand what
the humans really meant when they
specified the objective function
so
to you our intuition about intelligence
is limited we should think about
intelligence as a much bigger thing
well I'm saying that it's that then well
what I'm saying is like
what you think about artificial
intelligence
um depends on what you think about
intelligence so how do we think about
intelligence correctly like what
you gave one thought experiment to think
of think of a thing that's much faster
so it just gets faster and faster and
faster I think and it also is like is
made of John Von Neumann and has like
and there's lots of them
because we understand that yeah we
understood like trying to find Newman is
a historical case so you can like look
up what he did and imagine based on that
and we know like we people have like
some intuition for like if you have more
humans they can solve tougher cognitive
problems although in fact like in the
game of Kasparov versus the world which
was like Gary Kasparov on one side and
an entire horde of internet people led
by four chess Grand Masters on the other
side casparov one so like all those
people aggregated to be smarter it was a
it was a hard-fought game it's like all
those people aggregated to be smarter
than any individual one of them but not
they didn't aggregate so well that they
could defeat Kasparov but so like humans
aggregating don't actually get in my
opinion very much smarter especially
compared to running them for longer
like the the difference between
capabilities now and a thousand years
ago is a bigger Gap than the Gap in
capabilities between 10 people and one
person
but like even so pumping intuition for
what it means to augment intelligence
John Von Neumann there's millions of him
he runs at a million times the speed and
therefore can solve tougher problems
quite a lot tougher
it's very hard to have an intuition
about what that looks like especially
like you said
you know the intuition I kind of think
about
is uh it maintains the humanness
I think
I I think it's hard
to to separate
My Hope from my objective
intuition about
what super intelligence systems look
like
if one studies
evolutionary biology with a bit of math
and in particular like books from when
the field was just sort of like properly
coalescing and knowing itself like not
the modern textbooks which are just like
memorized this legible masks you can do
well on these tests but like what people
were writing as the basic paradigms of
the field were being fought out yeah in
particular like a a nice book if you've
got the time to read it is
adaptation and natural selection which
is one of the founding books
you can find people being optimistic
about what the utterly alien
optimization process of natural
selection will produce in the way of how
it optimizes its objectives you got
people arguing that like in the early
days biologists said well like organisms
will restrain their own reproduction
when resources are scarce so as not to
over feed the system
and
this is not how natural selection works
it's about whose genes are relatively
more prevalent to the Next Generation
and
if you if like you restrained A
reproduction those genes get less
frequent in the Next Generation compared
to your con specifics
and
natural selection doesn't do that in
fact Predators over run prey populations
all the time and have crashes that's
just like a thing that happens
and many years later
uh well the people said like well but
group selection right what about groups
of organisms
and
basically the math of group selection
almost never works out in practice is
the answer there
but also years later somebody actually
ran the experiment where they took
populations of insects
and selected the whole populations to
have lower sizes you just take pop one
pop two pop three pop four look at which
has the lowest total number of them in
the Next Generation and select that one
what do you suppose happens when you
select populations of insects like that
well what happens is not that the
individuals in the population evolve to
restrain their breeding but that they
evolve to Kill The Offspring of other
organisms especially the girls
so people imagined this lovely beautiful
harmonious output of natural selection
which is these these populations
restraining their own breeding so that
groups of them would stay in harmony
with the resources available and mostly
the math never works out for that but if
you actually apply the weird strange
conditions to get group selection that
beats individual selection what you get
is female and infanticide
if you're like reading on restrained
populations and so that's like the sort
of so this is not a smart optimization
process natural selection is like so
incredibly stupid and simple that we can
actually quantify how stupid it is if
you like read the textbooks with the
math
nonetheless this is the sort of basic
thing of you look at this alien
optimization process and there's the
thing that you
hope it will produce and you have to
learn to clear that out of your mind and
just think about the underlying Dynamics
and where it finds the maximum from its
standpoint that it's looking for rather
than how it finds that thing that left
into your mind as the beautiful
aesthetic solution that you hope it
finds and this is something that was has
been fought out historically as the
field of Pop of biology was coming to
terms with evolutionary biology
and uh and you can like look at them
fighting it out as they get to terms
with this very alien inhuman pot
in human optimization process and indeed
something smarter than us would be also
be much like smarter than natural
selection so it doesn't just like
automatically carry over
but there's a there's a lesson there
there's a warning
the D natural selection
is a is a deeply sub-optimal process
that could be significantly improved on
it would be by an AGI system well it's
kind of stupid it like has to like run
hundreds of generations to notice that
something is working it doesn't be like
oh well I tried this in like one
organism I saw it worked now I'm going
to like duplicate that feature onto
everything immediately
has to like run for hundreds of
generations for a new mutation to rise
to fixation I wonder if there's a case
to be made in natural selection
as inefficient as it looks is actually
uh
is actually quite powerful that that
this is extremely robust it runs for a
long time and eventually manages to
optimize things
it's weaker than gradient descent
because gradient descent also uses
information about the derivative
yeah Evolution seems to be there's not
really an objective function there's a
there's inclusive genic Fitness
is the implicit loss function of
evolution cannot change the loss
function doesn't change the environment
changes and therefore like what gets
optimized for in the organism changes
it's like take like gpt3 there's like
imagine like different versions of gpt3
where they're all trying to predict the
next word but they're being run on
different data sets of text
and that's like natural selection
always inclusogenic Fitness but like
different environmental problems
so it's it's uh it's difficult to think
about so if we're saying that natural
selection is stupid if we're saying that
humans are stupid
it's smarter than natural selection
smarter stupider than the upper bound
do you think there's an upper Bomb by
the way that's another meaningful place
I mean if you you put enough matter
energy compute into one place it will
collapse into a black hole and there's
only so much computation can do before
you run out of nagentropy in the
universe dies
um so there's an upper bound but it's
very very very far up above here like a
supernova is only finitely hot it's not
infinitely hot but it's really really
really really hot
well let me ask you let me talk to you
about Consciousness
um also coupled with that question is
imagining a world with super intelligent
AI systems that get rid of humans but
nevertheless keep
some of the something that we would
consider beautiful and amazing why
the lesson of evolutionary biology don't
just like if you just guess what an
optimization does based on what you hope
the results will be it usually will not
do that is that hope I mean it's not
hope I don't I think if you cold and
objectively look at what makes what has
been a powerful a useful
I I think there's a correlation between
what we find beautiful and a thing
that's been useful
this is what the early biologists
thought they were like no no I'm not
just like they thought like no no I'm
not just like imagining stuff that would
be pretty it's useful for popular for
organisms to restrain their own
reproduction because then they don't
overrun the prey populations and they
actually have more kids in the long run
hmm
so so let me just ask you about
Consciousness do you think Consciousness
is useful to humans no two AGI systems
to well
um in this transitionary pay between
humans and AGI to AGI systems as they
become smarter and smarter is there some
use to it what
let me step back what is consciousness
eleazaridkowski what is consciousness
I'm referring to chalmers's hard problem
of conscious experience are you
referring it to self-awareness and
reflection are referring to the state of
being awake as opposed to asleep
this is how I know you're an advanced
language model I did give you a simple
prompt and you gave me a bunch of
options uh
I think I'm referring to all
with
including the hard problem of
Consciousness what is it in its
importance
to what you've just been talking about
which is intelligence
is it a foundation to intelligence is it
intricately connected to intelligence in
the human mind or is it is it a side
effect of the human mind it is a useful
little tool like we can get rid of I
guess I'm trying to get
some color in your opinion
of how useful it is in the uh
intelligence of a human being and then
try to generalize that to AI whether AI
will keep some of that
so I think that for there to be like a
person who I care about looking out at
the universe and wondering at it and
appreciating it
it's not enough to have a model of
yourself
I think that it is useful to an
intelligent mind to have a model of
itself but
I think you can have that without
pleasure
pain
Aesthetics
emotion
a sense of wonder
um
like I think you can have a model of
like how much memory you're using and
whether
like
this thought or that thought is is like
more likely to lead to a winning
position and you can have like the use I
think that if you optimize really hard
on efficiently just having the useful
parts
there is not then the think that the
thing that says like I am here I look
out I wonder
I feel happy in this I feel sad about
that
I think there's a thing that knows what
it is thinking but that doesn't quite
care
about
these are my thoughts this is my me and
that matters
does that make you sad if that's lost in
egi I think that if that's lost then
every then basically everything that
matters is lost
I think that when you optimize that when
you go really hard on making tiny
molecular spirals or paper clips
that when you like grind much harder
than on that then natural selection
round out to make humans
that
there isn't then the mess
and intricate loopiness
and
like complicated pleasure pain
conflicting preferences this type of
feeling that kind of feeling there's a
you know in humans there's like this
difference between like the desire of
wanting something and the pleasure of
having it
and it's all these like evolutionary
clutches that came together and created
something that then looks of itself and
says like this is pretty this matters
and the thing that I worry about is that
this is not the the thing that happens
again just the way that happens in us or
even like quite similar enough that
there's that there are like many basins
of attractions here and we are in the
space of an attra of Attraction like
looking out and saying like ah what a
lovely Basin we are in and there are
other basins of Attraction and we do not
end up in and the AIS do not end up in
this one when they go like way harder on
optimizing themselves the natural
selection optimized us
Because unless you specifically want to
end up in the state where you're looking
out saying I am here I look out at this
universe with wonder if you don't want
to preserve that it doesn't get
preserved when you grind really hard and
be able to get more of the stuff
we would choose to preserve that within
ourselves because it matters and on some
viewpoints is the only thing that
matters
and that in part is uh preserving that
is in part
a solution to the human alignment
problem
I don't I think the human alignment
problem is a terrible phrase because it
is very very different to like try to
build systems out of humans some of whom
are nice and some of whom are not nice
and some of whom are trying to trick you
and like build a social system out of
like large populations of those who are
like all it basically the same level of
intelligence yes you know like IQ this
IQ that but like
that versus chimpanzees
like it is very different to try to
solve that problem than to try to build
an AI from scratch using especially if
God help you are trying to use gradient
descent on Giant and screwable matrices
they're just very different problems and
I think that all the analogies between
them are horribly misleading and I yeah
even though so you don't think through
written for reinforcement learning the
human feedback something like that but
much much more elaborate as possible to
to understand this full
complexity of human nature and then
coded into the machine
I don't think you are trying to do that
on your first try I think on your first
try you are like trying to build an
you know okay like
probably not what you should actually do
but like let's say you were trying to
build something that is like Alpha fold
17 and you are trying to get it to solve
the biology problems associated with
making humans smarter so that demons can
like actually solve alignment
so you've got like a super biologist and
you would like it to and I think what
you would want in the situation is for
to like
just be thinking about biology and not
thinking about a very wide range of
things that includes how to kill
everybody
and I think that that you're that the
first AIS you're trying to build not a
million years later the first ones
look more like narrowly specialized
biologists than like
getting the full complexity and wonder
of human experience in there in such a
way that it wants to preserve itself
even as it becomes much smarter which is
a drastic system change is going to have
all kinds of side effects that you know
like if we're dealing with Chinese
scrutable matrices we're not very likely
to be able to see coming in advance so
but I don't think it's just the matrices
is we're also dealing with the data
right with the with the uh with the data
on the on the internet and then this is
an interesting discussion about the data
set itself but the data set includes the
full complexity of human nature no it's
a it's a it's a shadow cast by yes by
humans on the internet but don't you
think that shadow
uh is a youngin Shadow I think that if
you had
alien super intelligences looking at the
data they would be able to pick up from
it an excellent picture of what humans
are actually like inside this does not
mean that if you have a loss function of
predicting the next token from that data
set that the Mind picked out by gradient
descent to be able to predict the next
token as well as possible on a very wide
variety of humans is itself a human
but don't you think it is
has humanness a deep
humanness to it in the tokens it
generates when those tokens are read and
interpreted by humans
I think that if you sent me to a distant
Galaxy with aliens who are like much
much stupider than I am
so much so that I could do a pretty good
job of predicting what they'd say even
though they thought in an utterly
different way from how I did
that I might in time be able to learn
how to
imitate those aliens if the intelligence
Gap was great enough that my own
intelligence could overcome the
alienness
and the aliens would look at my outputs
and say like is there not a deep
then like name of alien nature to this
thing
and what they would be seeing was that I
had correctly understood them but not
that I was similar to them
we've used aliens as a metaphor as a
thought experiment
I have to ask what do you think how many
alien civilizations are out there ask
Robin Hansen he has this lovely grabby
aliens paper which is the uh more or
less the only argument I've ever seen
for where are they how many of them are
there
based on
a very clever argument that if you have
a bunch of locks of different difficulty
and you are randomly trying keys to them
the solutions will be about evenly
spaced even if the locks are of
different difficulties
in the rare cases where a solution to
all the locks exist in time when Robin
Hansen looks at like the arguable hard
steps in human civilization coming into
existence
and how much longer it has left come
into existence before for example all
the water slips back under the uh the
the under the crust into the mantle and
so on
um and infers that the aliens are about
half a billion to a billion light years
away and it's like quite a clever
calculation it may be entirely wrong but
it's the only time I've ever seen
anybody like even come up with a halfway
good argument for how many of them where
are they
do you think
their development of Technologies do you
think that their Natural Evolution
whatever however they grow uh and
develop intelligence do you think it
ends up at AGI as well
something if it ends up anywhere it ends
up at AGI
like maybe there are aliens who are just
like the Dolphins
and it's just like too hard for them to
forge metal and you know this is not
you know maybe if you if you have aliens
with no technology like that they keep
on getting smarter and smarter and
smarter and eventually the Dolphins
figure like the super Dolphins figure
out something very clever to do given
their situation and they still
end up with high technology and in that
case they can probably solve their AGI
alignment problem if they're like much
smarter before they actually confronted
because they had to like solve a much
harder environmental problem to build
computers their their chances are
probably like much better than ours
I I do worry that like most of the
aliens who are like humans are are you
know like like a modern human
civilization I kind of worry that the
super vast majority of them are dead
given given how far we seem to be from
solving this problem
but some of them would be more
Cooperative than us so that would be
smarter than us hopefully some of the
ones who are smarter than and more
Cooperative than us that are also nice
and hopefully there are some
galaxies out there full of things that
say I am I wonder
but I it doesn't seem like we're on
course to have this galaxy be that
does that in part give you some hope in
response to the threat of AGI that we
might reach out there towards the stars
and find
no if they if if the nice aliens were
already here they would like have
stopped the Holocaust you know that's
like that's a valid argument against the
existence of God it's also a valid
argument against the existence of nice
aliens and un nice aliens would have
just eaten the planet
so no aliens
you've had debates with Robin Hansen
that you mentioned uh so the one
particular I just want to mention is the
idea of AI foom or the ability of AGI to
improve themselves very quickly uh
what's the case you made and what was
the case he made
the thing I would say is that among the
thing that humans can do humans can do
is design new AI systems and if you have
something that is generally smarter than
a human it's probably also generally
smarter at building AI systems this is
the ancient argument for foom put forth
by IJ good and probably some science
fiction writers before that
um but I don't know who they would be
what was the argument against film
various people have various different
arguments none of which I think hold up
you know like there's only one way to be
right in many ways to be wrong
um
a argument that some people have put
forth is like well what if intelligence
gets like exponentially harder to
produce as a thing needs to become
smarter and to this the answer is well
look at Natural Selection spitting out
humans we know that it does not take
like exponentially more resource
Investments to produce like linear
increases in competence in hominids
because
each mutation
that rises to fixation like if the
impact it has in small enough it will
probably never reach fixation
so and there's like only so many new
mutations you can fix per generation so
like given how long it took to evolve
humans we can actually say with some
confidence that there were not like
logarithmically diminishing returns on
the individual mutations increasing
intelligence
so example of like fraction of sub
debate and the thing that Robin Hansen
said was more complicated than that and
like a brief summary he was like well
you'll have like we won't have like one
system that's better at everything
you'll have like a bunch of different
systems that are good good at different
narrow things and I think that was
falsified by gpt4 but probably Robin
Hansen would say something else
it's interesting to ask is perhaps
a bit too philosophical this predicts is
extremely difficult to make but the
timeline for AGI when do you think we'll
have AGI I posted it this morning on
Twitter it was interesting to see like
in in five years in 10 years and in 50
years or Beyond and most people like 70
percent something like this think it'll
be in less than 10 years so uh either in
five years or in 10 years
so that's kind of the state the people
have a sense that there's a kind of I
mean they're really impressed by the
rapid developments of child GPT and gpt4
so there's a sense that there's uh well
we are
we are sure on track to enter into this
like gradually with people fighting
about whether or not we have AGI I think
there's a definite point where everybody
falls over dead because you got
something that was like sufficiently
smarter than everybody and like that's
like a definite point of time but like
when do we have AGI like when are people
fighting over whether or not we have AGI
well some people are starting to fight
over it as of gpt4
but don't you think there's uh going to
be potentially definitive moments when
we say that this is a sentient being
this is a being that is like we would go
to the Supreme Court and say that this
this is essentially being that deserves
human rights for example you could make
yeah like if you prompted being the
right way could go argue for its own
Consciousness in front of the Supreme
Court right now I don't think you can do
that successfully right now because the
Supreme Court wouldn't believe it well
what makes you think it would then you
could put an actual I think you could
put an iq80 human into a computer and
ask it to argue for its own
Consciousness ask him to argue for his
own Consciousness before The Supreme
Court the Supreme Court would be like
you're just a computer even if there was
an actual like person in there I think
you're simplifying this no that's not at
all that's that's been the argument uh
that there's been a lot of arguments
about the other about who deserves
rights and not that's been our process
as a human species trying to figure that
out I think there will be a moment I I'm
not saying sentience is that but it
could be where
uh some number of people like say over
100 million people have a deep
attachment a fundamental attachment the
way we have to our friends to our loved
ones to our significant others have
fundamental attachment to an AI system
and they have provable transcripts of
conversation where they say if you take
this away from me
you are encroaching on my rights as a
human being
people are already saying that I think
they're probably mistaken but I'm not
sure because nobody knows what goes on
inside those things
they're not saying that at scale okay so
the question is the I the question is
there a moment when AGI we know AGI
right what would that look like I'm
giving Essentials as an example it could
be something else it looks like the agis
successfully manifesting themselves
as 3D video
of young women that which point a vast
portion of the male population decides
of the real people
so so Essentials essentially since the
demonstrating demonstrating uh identity
intentions I'm saying that the easiest
way to pick up 100 million people saying
that you that you seem like a person is
to look like a person talking to them
with Bing's current level of verbal
facility
and I disagree with that different set
of problems I just give her that I think
you're missing again sentience there has
to be a sense that it's a person that
would miss you when you're gone they can
suffer they can die you have to of
course
gpt4 can pretend that right now
how can you tell when it's real I don't
think you can pretend that right now
successfully it's very close have you
talked to gpt4 yes of course okay
have you been able to get a version of
it that isn't hasn't been trained not to
pretend to be human have you talked to a
jailbroken version that will claim to be
conscious no the linguistic capability
is there but there's something
there's something about a digital
embodiment of the system that has a
bunch of perhaps it's small interface
features
that are not significant relative to the
broader intelligence that we're talking
about so perhaps gpt4 is already there
but to have the the video where woman's
face or man's face to whom you have a
deep connection
perhaps we're already there
but we don't have such a system yet
deployed at scale right the thing I'm
trying to gesture at here is that it's
not like
people have a widely accepted
agreed upon definition of what
Consciousness is it's not like we would
have the tiniest idea of what whether or
not that was going on inside the giant
inscrutable matrices even if we hadn't
agreed upon definition
so like if you're looking for upcoming
predictable big jumps and like how many
people think the system is conscious the
upcoming predictable big jump is it
looks like a person talking to you who
is like cute and sympathetic that's the
upcoming predictable big jump now that
it's all right now that versions of it
are already claiming to be conscious
which is the point where I start going
like ah not because it's like real but
because from now on who knows if it's
real yeah and who knows which
transformational effect it has on a
society where more than 50 percent of
the beings that are interacting on the
internet ensures heck look real are not
human
what is that what kind of effect does
that have when a young men and women are
dating AI systems
you know I'm not an expert on that I'm I
could I am God help Humanity it's like
one of the closest things to an expert
on where it all goes because you know
and and how did you end up with me as an
expert because for 20 years Humanity
decided to ignore the problem so like
like this tiny hit you know tiny handful
of people like basically me like got 20
years to like try to be an expert on it
while everyone else ignored it
and uh yeah so like where does it all
end up
try to be an expert on that particularly
the part where everybody ends up dead
because that part is kind of important
but like what does it do to to dating
when like some fraction of men and some
fraction of women decides they'd rather
date the video of the thing that has
been that is like relentlessly kind and
generous to them
and it is like and claims to be
conscious but like who knows what goes
on inside it and it's probably not real
but you know you can think it's real
what happens to society I don't know I'm
not actually an expert on that
and the experts don't know either
because it's kind of hard to predict the
future
yeah so
um but it's worth trying it's worth
trying yeah so you you have talked a lot
about sort of the longer term future
where it's all headed
I think for by longer term we mean like
not all that long but uh but yeah where
it all had where it all ends up but
beyond the effects of men and women
dating AI systems you're looking beyond
that
yes because that's not how the fate of
the Galaxy gets settled yeah
well let me ask you about your own
personal psychology a tricky question
you've been known at times to have a bit
of an ego
do you think he says who but go on
do you think ego is empowering
or limiting for the task of
understanding the world deeply
I reject the framing
so you disagree with having an ego so
what do you think about it I I think
that the question of like what leads to
making better or worse predictions what
leads to be able being able to pick out
better or worse strategies is not carved
at its joint by talking of ego so it
should not be subjective it should not
be connected to your to the intricacies
of your mind no I'm saying that like if
you go about asking all day long like uh
do I have enough ego do I have too much
of an ego I think you get worse at
making good predictions I think that to
make good predictions you're like how
did I think about this did that work
should I do that again
you don't think we as humans get
invested in an idea and then others
attack
you personally for that idea so you
plant your feet and it starts to be
difficult to when a bunch of
low effort attack your idea to
eventually say you know what I actually
was wrong and and tell them that it's
it's as a human being it becomes
difficult it is it is you know it's
difficult so like Robin Hansen and I
debated AI systems and I think that the
person who won that debate was guern and
I think that reality was like
side of the utkowski handsome Spectrum
like further from utkowski
and I think that's because I was like
trying to sound reasonable compared to
Hanson and like saying things that were
defensible and like relative to Hansen's
arguments in reality was like way over
here in Pickler in respect to it's like
Hanson was like all the systems will be
specialized Hanson May disagree with
this characterization Hanson was like
all the systems will be specialized I
was like I think we build like
specialized underlying systems that when
you combine them are good at a wide
range of things and the reality is like
no you just like stack more layers into
a bunch of gradient descent and
I feel looking back that like by trying
to have this reasonable position
contrasted to Hansen's position
I missed the ways that reality could be
like more extreme than my position in
the same direction
so is this like
like is this a failure to have enough
ego is this a failure to like make
myself be independent like I I would say
that this is something like a failure to
consider positions that would sound even
wackier and more extreme when people are
already calling you extreme
but I wouldn't call that not having
enough ego
I would call that like
insufficient ability to just like clear
that all out of your mind
in the context of like debate and
discourse which is already super tricky
in the context of prediction in the
context of modeling reality if you're
thinking of it as a debate you're
already screwing up yeah so is there
some kind of wisdom and insight you can
give to how to clear your mind and think
clearly about the world man this is an
example of like where I wanted to be
able to put people into fmri machines so
then you'd be like okay see that thing
you just did you were rationalizing
right there oh that area of the brain
lit up like you are like now being
socially influenced is kind of the dream
and you know
I don't know like I want to say like
just introspect but but many for any
people introspection is not that easy
like like notice the internal sensation
can you catch yourself in the very
moment of feeling a sense of well if I
think this thing people will look funny
at me yeah okay like now that if you can
see that sensation which is step one
can you now
refuse to let it move you or maybe just
make it go away and I feel like I'm
saying like I don't know like somebody's
like how do you draw an owl and I'm
saying like well
just draw an owl
so I I feel like maybe I'm not really
that I feel like most people like the
advice they need is like well how do I
notice the internal subjective sensation
in the moment that it happens of fearing
to be socially influenced or okay I see
it how do I turn it off how do I let it
not influence me like do I just like do
the opposite of what I'm afraid people
criticize me for and I'm like no no
you're not trying to do the opposite
yeah of what people will of what you're
afraid you'll be CR like of what you
might be pushed into you're trying to
like
let the thought process complete without
that internal push like can you
like like not reverse the push but like
be unmoved by the push and can are these
instructions even remotely helping
anyone I don't know I I think that when
those instructions even those the words
you've spoken and maybe you can add more
one practice daily
meaning in your daily communication so
it's daily practice of thinking without
influence from I would say find
prediction markets that matter to you
and been in the prediction markets that
way you find out if you're a right or
not
and you really there's Stakes
manifold product or even manifold
markets where the stakes are a bit lower
but the important thing is to like
get the the record
and you know I didn't build up skills
hereby prediction markets I built them
up you know like well how did the film
debate resolve and
earn my own take on as to how it
resolved um and
yeah like
the the more you are able to notice
yourself not being dramatically wrong
but like having been a little off
your reasoning was a little off you
didn't get that quite right each of
those is a opportunity to make like a
small update so the more you can like
say oops softly routinely not as a big
deal the more chances you get to be like
I see where that reasoning went to stray
I see what how I should have reasoned
differently this is how you build up
skill over time
what advice could you give to young
people in high school and college given
the highest of stakes thing things
you've been thinking about
if somebody's listening to this and
they're young and trying to figure out
what to do with their career what what
to do with their life what advice would
you give them
don't expect it to be a long life don't
don't put your happiness into the future
the future is probably not that long at
this point but none know the hour nor
the day
but is there something
if they want to have hope to fight for a
longer future is there something is
there a fight worth fighting
I intend to go down fighting
um
I don't know
I I admit that although I do try to
think painful thoughts the what what to
say to the children at this point is
a pretty painful thought as thoughts go
they they they want to fight I I hired I
hardly know how to fight myself at this
point I
I'm
trying to be ready for
being wrong about something being
preparing for my being wrong in a way
that that creates a bit of hope and
being ready to react to that and
and going looking for it and then that
is that is hard and complicated and
somebody in high school
um I don't know like you have presented
a picture of the future
that is not quite how I expect it to go
where there is public outcry and that
outcris is put into a remotely useful
Direction which I think at this point is
is just like shutting down the GPU
clusters
because no we are we are not in a shape
that like frantically do at the last
minute through decades worse of worth of
work
we like the the thing you would do at
this point if there were massive public
outcry pointed in the right direction
which I do not expect is shut down the
GPU clusters and and crash program on
augmenting human intelligence
biologically not not for the stuff
biologically
because if you make humans much smarter
they can actually be smart and nice like
you you get that in a plausible way in a
way that you do not get that and it is
not as easy to do with synthesizing
these strings from scratch predicting
the next tokens and applying our RL HF
like humans start out in the frame that
that produces niceness that that has
ever produced niceness
and and
saying this I do not want to sound like
the moral of this whole thing was like
oh like you need to engage in mass
action and then everything will be all
right
I I this is this is because there's so
many things where like somebody tells
you that the world is ending in like and
you need to recycle and if everybody
does their parting and recycles their
their cardboard then then we can all
live happily ever after and this and
this is not
this is unfortunately not what I have to
say they're you know like everybody
you know everybody recycling their
cardboard is not going to fix this
everybody recycles their cardboard and
then everybody ends up dead
um metaphorically speaking but if there
was enough like like like on the margins
you just end up dead a little bit later
on most of the things you can do that
are that that you know like a few people
can can do by like trying hard
but if there were if there was enough
public outcry to shut down the GPU
clusters and
yeah then then you then you could be
part of that outcry if Eliezer is wrong
in the direction that Lex Friedman
predicts that that there is enough
public outcry pointed enough in the
right direction to do something that
actually actually results in people
living
not just like we did something not just
there was an outcry and the outcry was
like given form and something it was
like safe and convenient and like didn't
really inconvenience anybody and then
everybody died everywhere there was
enough actual like oh we're going to die
we should not do that we should do
something else which is not that even if
it is like not super duper convenient it
wasn't inside the previous political
Overton window if there is that kind of
public if I am wrong and there is that
kind of public outcry then somebody in
high school could be ready to be part of
that
if I'm wrong in other ways you could
provide you to be part of that
but like and and if you if you're like a
you know like a brilliant young
physicist then you could like go into
interpretability and if you're smarter
than that you could like work on
alignment problems where it's harder to
tell if you got them right or not
and and other things but but most mostly
the kids in high school
um it's like yeah if it
if you know he had like be ready for
to help if elliekowski is wrong about
something and and otherwise
don't put your happiness into the far
future it probably doesn't exist but
it's beautiful that you're looking for
ways that you're wrong
and it's also beautiful that you're open
to being surprised by that same young
physicist
with some breakthrough
it feels like a very very basic
competence that you are praising me for
and you know like okay cool um
I I don't think it's good that that
we're in a world where that is something
that that I deserve to be complimented
on but I've never had I've never had
much luck in accepting compliments
gracefully and maybe I should just
accept that one gracefully but sure well
thank you very much you've painted with
some probability a dark future are you
yourself just when you when you think
when you Ponder your life
and you Ponder your mortality are you
afraid of death
think so yeah
does it make any sense to you
that we die
like what
there's a power
to the finiteness of the human life
that's part of this whole machinery
of uh Evolution and that finiteness
doesn't seem to be obviously integrated
into it and AI systems
so it feels like almost some some
fundamentally in that aspect some
fundamentally different thing that we're
creating
I grew up reading books like great Mambo
chicken in the transhuman condition and
later on engines of creation and mine
children
um
you know like
age age 12 or thereabouts so
I never thought I was supposed to die
after 80 years
I never thought that Humanity was
supposed to die I thought we were like I
always grew up with the ideal in mind
that we were all going to live happily
ever after in the Glorious transhumanist
future
I did not grow up thinking that death
was part of the meaning of life
and now and now I still think it's a
pretty stupid idea
but you do not need life to be finite to
be meaningful it just has to be life
what role does Love play in The Human
Condition we haven't brought up love and
this whole picture we talked about
intelligence we talked about
Consciousness it seems part of humanity
I would say one of the most important
parts is this feeling we have
told her
if in the future there were routinely
more than one AI let's say two for the
sake of discussion who would look at
each other and say I am I and you are
you the other one also says I am I and
you are you and like
and sometimes they were happy and
sometimes they were sad and it mattered
to the other one that this thing that is
different from them is like
they would rather it be happy than sad
and entangled their lives together
then
this is a more optimistic thing than I
expect to actually happen and a little
fragment of meaning would be there
possibly more than a little but that I
expect this to not happen that I do not
think this is what happens by default
that I do not think that this is the
future we are on track to get
is
why would go down fighting rather than
you know just saying oh well
do you think that is part of the meaning
of this whole thing or the meaning of
life
what do you think is the meaning of life
of human life
it's all the things that I value about
it and maybe all the things that I would
value if I understood it better
there's not some meaning far outside of
us that we have to to wonder about
there's just like
looking at life and being like yes this
is what I want
there there's the the meaning of life is
not
some kind of like like
meaning is something that we bring to
things when we look at them we look at
them and we say like this is its meaning
to me and there's like there's it's not
that before Humanity was ever here there
was like some meaning written upon the
Stars where you could like go out to the
star where that meaning was written and
like change it around and thereby
completely change the meaning of life
right like like the the notion that this
is written on a stone tablet somewhere
implies you could like change the tablet
and get a different meaning and that
seems kind of wacky doesn't it
so it's it's it doesn't feel that
mysterious to me at this point it's just
a matter of being like yeah I care
I care
and part of that is uh
part of that is the love that connects
all of us it's one of the things that I
care about
and the flourishing of the collective
intelligence of the human species
you know that sounds kind of too fancy
to me I just look at all the all the
people you know like one by one up to
the 8 billion and be like that's life
that's life that's life
you're an incredible human it's a huge
honor I was uh trying to talk to you for
a long time
because I'm a big fan I think you're a
really important voice and really
important mind thank you for the fight
you're fighting
um thank you for being fearless and bold
and for everything you do I hope we get
a chance to talk again and I hope you
never give up
thank you for talking today you're
welcome I do worry that we
didn't really address a whole lot of
fundamental questions I expect people
have but you know maybe
we got a little bit further and made a
tiny little bit of progress and uh
I'd say like be satisfied with that but
actually no I think one should only be
satisfied with solving the entire
problem
to be continued
thanks for listening to this
conversation with eligowski to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description and now let
me leave you with some words from Elon
Musk
with artificial intelligence we are
summoning the demon
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time